Hello, hello.
Welcome, welcome, welcome, welcome.
Congrats on the concert.
Thank you.
If you saw and...
Oh no, I'm already yawning.
Sorry.
Oh my gosh, I'm still so sleepy.
Today, all I did was watch...
All I did was watch Breaking Bad.
And I watched K-Pop Demon Hunters because I got Netflix so
that I could watch Breaking Bad.
are you having been watching it i i don't think i would
still be binging it if i didn't like it so much i think i
was like oh wait now hot dog indeed i was like if i if i
could do if i have netflix for one thing so basically what
i'm gonna do is i'm gonna try and watch as much breaking bad
as i can And then I will...
Also, watch everything else on Netflix that I wanted to
watch, but I never wanted to get Netflix for.
Haven't met Gus yet.
And then I will...
I will... I will then cancel Netflix.
Hello, Ammito, and I...
Uh...
What was that?
There was like a force stopping me.
from saying Aibu.
Sorry.
I'm a little...
Still, my voice is a little icky.
They give over to Jars.
Thank you!
Minto, we need to cook.
Your voice is no longer dead.
It's only a little dead.
The Force hates Aibu.
If I can't say it...
Normal.
Are you ever going to settle on a fan name?
I literally just did!
What are you talking about?
What was I saying?
I don't remember.
But yeah.
I boo-boo.
My concert?
Oh, did you see the...
Wait, hold on.
I have the image.
image, image, image, what's it called?
What's the, what is this one?
I didn't know when they were going to announce it.
Rather, when I said that I would have an announcement, I
thought I would be announcing it.
But it was announced on Twitter.
But yeah, be doing an in-person 3d jazz concert with a live
band and some special guests um so far most of them are
confirmed there's one person that i am waiting to hopefully
hear back from but but it should still be a really great
show Yes.
What was I going to say?
It's at this place called the Peppermint Club, which, of
course, is like such a great...
Oh, my gosh.
Wow, thank you!
Let this red super be my catalyst to win the Hunger Games
and get a ticket.
That's like, oh, it was so fun.
Thank you.
I...
What was it?
Uh...
um the name the the club name itself is just so perfect but
also um the club itself is quite small uh so if you don't
get a ticket that's totally okay um there it would also it
will also be streaming so you know it would be kind of fun
if maybe some people got together for like uh for like a
live viewing um a fancy valentine's party or something maybe
yeah it looks like a really snazzy place right like it's and
it's also you know it's gonna be a jazz concert so it's not
like your i guess typical idol type vtuber idol show so it's
gonna be pretty low-key return of the red dress I don't
know.
So, should I wear a suit?
You could totally wear a suit.
And it would fit, I think.
But, it's not so, like, no fun allowed.
We're obviously still allowing fun.
You know, don't feel like you have to be on your bestest
behavior.
But, you know, you could even mix to the songs if you wanted
to.
But they're all jazz songs, so.
You know, bring a date.
I know you're going to be playing Ace Combat next year, but
I got a question.
Do you know the play order for the series yet?
Oh, I don't know yet, Nan.
I haven't had a chance to think about it.
Now, thank you so much for the time I got it.
Thank you.
I don't know yet.
I'll think about it.
I want everyone to show up wearing eye patches.
Yeah, you could show up as, like, snake wearing a suit.
When Minto concert in Europe,
A date?
What date?
I could be your date.
Would you want me to be your date for the Valentine's Day?
Jazz concert?
Life and I booked flights already.
Oh, wait, what do you mean?
Hopefully we can get tickets.
Wait, what do you mean you've already booked your flights?
Basically, the tickets will be up.
You can pre...
Like...
You can, like, register for the announcement of the tickets.
There was, like, some issues.
Not issues, but they're, like, waiting for something for the
actual tickets to go up themselves.
But, I was saying how it's not, like, super serious.
There is some merch.
I don't think there's so much merch.
But there's one thing in particular that is.
It's goofy.
Don't tease us like that.
What am I teasing?
Can I bring my henna plushes my data?
Of course.
I will steal her.
But, you know.
For Lord and Kip, welcome back!
Holiday, welcome back!
Hellsies, hellsies!
But yeah, there is a streaming ticket, so...
together with some friends.
Is it goofy or spicy?
Yes.
Bye.
It's stupid, that's for sure.
It's dummy dumb.
Hey, Liao, Jowun, thank you so much for the vibe, good
thing.
Ducky, thank you so much for the vibe, good thing.
Thank you, guys.
It's time for the smooth jazz.
Just wanted to say, hey, mid-annihilation of Eli and his
friend.
Wait, what do you mean?
Surgery went well.
Oh, Brandon, I'm so happy to hear that.
So happy, happy.
Get some rest.
Will merch be available online?
Most likely.
I don't know, but probably.
Probably.
But they have not received the confirmation.
Well, yeah, jazz, concert, live band, special guests, and
me.
I'm so nervous.
Because live band is, like, so scary.
What?
Oh, gosh.
If I mess up, if I mess up the live band, well, they don't
stop.
Oh, my gosh.
I don't know.
I'm so scared.
I'm never...
Ah, live jazz band.
Oh, scary.
Scary.
I feel like, I don't know.
Like, obviously, with Fantastic Reality, I had a live band,
but I was able to practice with, like, the, what's it
called?
The, um, like, they recorded something for me first.
I don't know if they're gonna do that for me this time.
I'm just gonna be winging it.
Maybe.
I have no idea.
to practice with like the kind of score that they were going
to use for fantastic reality of this i don't know i'm scared
if you mess up it's jazz that's so true
on a scale of one to ten how nervous are you like a hundred
i'm also i was scared i'm also scared that like i know it's
not during a convention or anything so i'm worried that like
it won't sell I was like I was like can I I mean I know that
there are special guests but like can I this is it's it's
kind of advertised almost like a solo show so uh I know it's
it's a bit of a smaller venue though so that made me feel a
bit better but um
oh sorry that was my controller for the game what is this on
my controller What is that?
It's getting dirty.
Lay Merry Christmas, Wiki!
Hope it was a great day for you.
Yeah!
It was fine.
It was okay.
I was flying home.
Back to my mid-cafe.
And my flight got, like, delayed a couple times.
And so I ended up coming home much later than I thought.
So it's a good thing I didn't plan on streaming.
It's going to sell out in the first minute.
No, no, no, no.
I don't think so.
Are you going to write your own jazz song?
I don't know.
Kimmy, thank you so much for the re-direct.
Hello, hello.
When will you learn that I boost show up?
I don't know.
Like I said, it's not during a...
event where many people you know like sometimes people will
travel for a convention or something i wouldn't expect
anybody to travel for this so so you know it's it's it makes
me nervous and i'm sorry that i just did the maid cafe in
california and now i'm doing another thing in california i'm
trying to think hold on let me think of this year there is
some more stuff in california happening that's for sure but
not only california in 2026 so
i just think california needs to stop inviting me there are
multiple people planning to travel from the east coast no no
that's so much though don't do that just all gathered
together on the East Coast.
And watch the stream.
I will be flying cross country.
Don't do that!
I will travel for this no matter what.
No!
Don't do it!
But, you know, I'm an East Coast...
I'm an East Coaster as well, so I do understand.
I have to travel to the West Coast for it even.
Even I have to travel.
I'm so tired of flying to the West Coast.
I'm so tired.
East Coast is coming forward.
Yeah.
I have some things for East Coast in 2026.
I can think of.
Midwest?
Hmm.
I don't know so far.
Have another event in Florida.
Oh, I'm glad that I'm not in Florida heat anymore.
Oh, my goodness.
Holiday Matsuri.
I definitely overpacked for it.
I thought I was like, oh, yeah, surely it will get chilly at
night.
I think there was one time that I was cold.
Everything else was hot, hot, hot.
Don't even have a passport.
Oh, no.
We'll be traveling from Canada land.
cries in european eyeball i'm sorry
i get it though my ocean is going to west coast soon and i
i'm just like i could go but i won't go and you know why i
won't go because i'm thinking of you guys and i'm thinking i
want to actually i i want to i don't this is not a formal
announcement but one thing that i do want to like my goals
for 2026 uh one of them is so funny one of my goals is like
to draw more and i've actually even kind of started just
like sketching things on my in my free time like when my
plane was delayed i was just kind of like drawing a little
bit but it was funny because i was like you know a while
back i was like maybe i'll start like you know i thought
that i think my art is so great or anything obviously
because it's it's not but and it's just like you know
whatever but i was like now it's kind of like not a great
time to be posting art so much huh i'll say hi to your oci
for you at a.m i shall be real confused thank you yes please
but um i think uh tomorrow i wanted to do some drawing on
stream maybe i'll draw some Maybe if you guys went to like a
profile picture or something.
I was thinking that tomorrow before the Densetsu collab.
But just like drawn and yapping.
Another one of my goals is...
I've been saying this.
I want like more consistent stream schedule.
Where like similar times and similar days every day.
And then also...
One thing I have planned for January.
for January.
Oh, wait.
Someone's messaging me.
Hold on.
Oh, the merch will be available online.
I was just told.
Thank you.
Thank you, Oshispaar.
But one thing that I want to do probably towards the end of
January is I want to do a full it's not going to be, I'm not
calling it a don't-a-thon or anything like that because I
don't want that to be the goal of it or anything.
But I plan on doing a full week of 24 hours streaming for
the whole week.
Non-stop for one week.
So just, you know, just to kind of like catch up on the fact
that I have been so not streaming for a bit.
So a whole week!
Yeah!
24 hours.
So yeah!
Not a Donothan.
I almost feel like maybe I should turn off Donoth.
But, uh, does that mean sleeping stream?
It means sleeping stream.
Yes, yes, yes.
So, um, it'll just be, it'll be pretty casual.
Just like, uh, you know, If you ever feel like coming in,
watching Minto, with whatever I'm doing, then yeah.
There you go.
Some non-stop entertainment for one week.
And then I'll sleep for a whole week.
No, I'm just kidding.
Feeding the cats.
24-7, let's go.
Almost too spooky.
Hi, Teggy.
Oh.
So, Minto-ton, yeah, because, you know, like, usually, I
guess, people on Twitch do them, like, Sabaton, or Donuton,
or whatever, but, I don't want to encourage people to, to
donate or anything like that, so I was thinking having other
stretch goals in different ways, like, I don't know, I've
been kind of, like, thinking, like, oh, if I, reach this I
don't know this many views or something non-stop meat
phantom yeah will you swap out the VOD so it isn't lost oh
good question I probably wouldn't be able to do that but
what I could do is I could say say I'm gonna be like doing a
game or something i could record that portion of the game
and then i could re-upload it um at a later time like say i
play who knows who knows say i play something then i could
upload it later
Alan Wake.
I think I want to do games like that, though.
That's like a stream.
Like its own individual.
I think.
Is this basement cult noise jazz?
Oh my gosh.
Should I?
Some of you guys might not know that story.
Okay, so one time I was invited to a jazz show.
Okay, I was in Japan.
I did not have any really friends.
I did not.
I did not have many friends, but there was one person in my
class that I got along with.
He was all right.
Like, we didn't really hang out, but he and I would talk in
class.
And one time, he was just like, hey, me too.
I know you're into jazz.
And I was like, yeah, I'm into jazz.
I love jazz, actually.
Like, unironically, call me the bee.
Yeah.
The B word.
But I remember this story.
Yeah, and so I was like...
He was like, I'm going to a jazz show tonight.
It's close to...
It's close to the school you want to come with?
I was like, okay, cool.
And so...
And for anybody...
I...
Anybody confused?
I'm pretty sure he had a girlfriend.
So, and if you're like, he was totally asking you on a date,
it definitely wasn't like that.
And especially, I think, hold on, anyway.
So, we get there, and it's in, like, in Japan, a lot of,
like, live houses and places are downstairs, like, in a
basement, right?
So, I was not, like, I was not thinking anything of it, that
it was in a basement or anything.
into the into the teeny tiny tiny little teeny little bar
and um i got my signature at the bar one orange juice please
so i was like okay i'm ready to appreciate some jazz with my
oj and it
was it was
musical instruments and and pots and pans that were being
like clanked on the wall it was just noise it was a and then
I was just kind of sitting there like kind of
in this moment yeah it was that kind of jazz it was I was
just taking I was like wow this is where I'm at oh my gosh
and there oh let's say maybe like I don't know this might be
this might be too many people but maybe ten other people in
the room oh I forgot to mention also that my friend he was
just like oh yeah this this is like a world famous jazz jazz
musician so i was like oh yeah jazz is all about improv
don't you know oh my gosh i need to i clearly i watched the
wrong la la land or something
and so and so i was like so excited and it was just such a
strange thing and I was like I was you know I kind of vibe
to anything I'm one of those people that I'll be like I
listen to anything and so you know I'm one of those I wasn't
any except country and rap no I'm just kidding um like I can
appreciate any kind of music for the most part but but then
I was like kind of vibing with everything and just taking it
all in and then the monk came out
and he was like
and he was like doing his ceremonial chance and it was just
like oh no no no way I'm the idiot I'm the stupid one I got
I got I'm getting sacrificed tonight the recipe called for
one spirit I don't know.
And I was like, no way.
And it was over.
And my friend was like, what'd you think?
And I was like, cool, bud.
And we didn't go anywhere.
We didn't hang out again.
Which is fine.
Was this classmate per chance interested in...
Roadrunner cartoons.
And that's how Minto became a spirit.
Maybe they were trying to exercise me.
Maybe he was like, hey, like he talked to them beforehand.
He was like, I got this ghost.
That's like, she just won't.
She just won't get it.
We gotta get her out of here.
They were like, okay, I got you.
I'll give her the Jazzy special.
for monks.
It is so crazy.
Merry Christmas, Minto.
I got you the gift of my first ever Super Chat.
Thank you!
Epic and thank you so much.
Merry Christmas!
It's so funny too because I can remember the club.
I can remember the... not the club, I guess the bar.
I can remember the outside of the bar and the inside of it
so well.
Like, it's so ingrained in my brain.
I want to go back.
Maybe I'll try and find it next time I go back to Japan.
Ghost Maid is too strong for jazz cult.
Yeah, Falafel Panda, thank you so much for that, thank you,
dude!
Dorigo, thank you so much!
Thank you.
Imagine if the monk started...
Is it scatting?
Scat manning.
I don't think the first word is correct.
It is.
That's what it's called.
Anyway, that's my jazz story when I talk about jazz.
And today we're playing easy delivery code.
Yeah, it has two meanings.
Well, obviously I knew about, like, the, I'm a scatman, and
I knew the, um, the other meme name.
But I didn't know if scatting was like...
Does it mean, buff?
Good day!
Thank you for all the happiness you brought us this year,
and you worked so hard, super hard in this show.
Also, Tascado for exposed shoulders.
Stop, stop, I'm shy.
Happy birthday!
Happy, happy birthday.
Yeah, jazz show!
I just came back from Florida.
It was hot.
I went to Disney.
I went to Sea World.
Got to beach about holiday material.
I was insanely nervous.
No!
Don't ever be nervous meeting me.
We're so chill.
It's so chill.
Thank you for being so nice and making my first ever
meeting.
Thank you, Bluefish, for coming to see me!
Uh, oh my god.
I...
It was...
Disney was so crazy.
Um...
It was my first time going to Disney Orlando in a many, many
time long.
And...
I got to try some of the new rides that I was like, you know
obviously I went on dinosaur because that was my that was my
only goal actually I only went to holiday Matsuri not the
not like guesting at the con but I only went I only haunted
the state so that I could go ride dinosaur
yeah I did make it we made I was like I I won't have... So
the ride closes February 2nd.
The ride closes February 2nd.
I don't have another chance to go!
And so I was like, I will go.
I will ride my favorite... one of my favorite rides for one
last time.
It's so... I've been sending... I've been sending, um, my
friends like...
TikToks of dinosaur and other people who are sad.
That are sad that the ride is closing.
One last ride before it went extinct.
I'm like so sad.
Did you record it to keep it forever?
No, other people have recorded it.
I just wanted to...
I wish I could show you.
I wish I could show you my picture.
So I, you know, obviously to ride rides, I have to possess a
person because otherwise, like, I'm just like floating
there.
It's not the same thing.
I want to experience it.
I want to experience the feeling of the ride.
So I have to possess a person and the face that she is
making is like...
It's like this, because obviously it's me, but I was just
like...
Like it's just this feeling, it's like this look, so you're
looking at the carnitores.
And I, and basically I'm like...
Just like, like this look of satisfaction and sadness just
so like...
Just like that, like so...
Oh, this is the last time I'm seeing you.
I think I'm gonna cry.
I think I'm thinking about dinosaur again and I'm gonna cry.
You're upstream.
I know!
Thank you for covering Bukamitaya because that was one of my
favorite games.
Keep up the good work, Minto!
Thank you!
It's so sad.
Could just adopt them.
But I was also sad because my favorite animatronic on the
ride was broken.
I was like, no!
Why could they...
Why would they get rid of it?
I'm so sad.
And I know it's...
What's also terrible is the ride itself is also the same
exact track as Indiana Jones.
So it's being rebranded into Indiana Jones.
But what's so funny is...
Jones so many times that like if I close if like certain
parts of dinosaur I was like oh yeah this part is that part
in Indiana Jones like a mother sending their child into the
world the mother should well I would hope a mom can see
their child again happy year and a month making thank you
thank you oh maybe you can buy one of the animatronics the
new place oh my gosh i want to buy the animatronic of
there's one of a dinosaur the one that's broken is my
favorite um it's a guy eating another dinosaur so basically
like starts down and then he lifts up and like the butt of
the other dinosaurs in his like sticking out of his mouth
is there a fave that one dinosaur that acts like a dog no
t-rex is not on dinosaur ride which is like that's why
partially i like it because i think besides like a raptor
there's like not and a i think like a is it a teradactyl i
cannot remember but like the dinosaurs on it like you are
saving the iguanodon who thinks about the iguanodon anymore
i do because because of dinosaur the ride but it's like it's
like non-conventional dinosaurs that they include and it's
so nice Like, you're not getting chased by a T-Rex.
You're getting chased by the Karnatour.
Thank you, thank you.
Normal people.
Mint, this is an intervention.
Mint's friend.
Mint, this is an exorcism.
Iguanodons are awesome.
Oh no!
They replaced T-Rex with Karnatourus to be different from
Jurassic Park.
I'll be honest, I don't remember the dinosaur movie that
it's, like, based off of.
But the fact that it's, like, a Karnatourus, and he looks so
cool too oh man man but yeah I'm sorry then what else I got
to ride um cosmic rewind I've never watched the guardians of
the galaxy before and it also did kind of ruin my mood that
I had to see Chris Pratt but the ride itself was so crazy
and I was like so basically it's a roller coaster and like
your seat spins while you're riding it.
And it's really, really cool.
And there's like five choices of songs that are gotcha.
Not the crisp red.
Yeah, I had to see him.
It was terrible.
But there's like five songs.
One of them's like, people don't like that one.
It doesn't really suit the theme of the song.
But one of the songs is September.
And I was like, please, please, please, give me September,
give me September.
I want to hear September.
And so basically, the ride, it starts and you're facing
backwards.
And it launches you.
It launches you backwards.
And as soon as it launches us backwards, I hear...
Oh my God!
awesome but a little little do you remember one if it's not
a September and I was like yeah I was so it was so awesome I
got September first time I tried it let's go I feel like it
suits the ride the bestest in my opinion how did your ghost
form not go through the seats um well mr.
Rowland I explained earlier that I have to possess somebody
so that I can get on the rides.
It's all possession.
All I do is possess, possess, possess, possess, possess.
People are so easy.
People are so, like, you know, your mental is weak.
Are you guys okay?
Hot dog.
I meant after the ride.
This is good, isn't it?
I literally looked like, I looked like, I looked like Big
Boss when he said that.
So you're possessive.
Maybe.
I mean, you wouldn't leave me, right?
Right?
I mean, like, that'd be so crazy.
Sorry I'm yapping so much.
I will play the game eventually.
Oh, I forgot it.
My controller doesn't really like it.
I forgot.
Pour one out for our dinosaur, homies.
Yeah!
Thank you, Mr. Mayhem.
you love the yaps i'll be yapping more tomorrow so and what
else so i got to ride cosmic rewind for the first time it
was really awesome um and then i went to magic kingdom and i
rode space mountain and i rode um which oh my god i was in
the back seat of of space mountain and that ride is like
whiplash crazy i and you know if you if you know about
roller coasters if you sit in the back you feel like
everything the most you're getting the most like whip and
whaps and everything it's old and intense i i i had bruises
on my arm i got bruises on my arm because i'm sitting on the
back of space mountain it kicked my booty i was like holy
cow it was so bad because it just kept whipping me around in
places it was crazy we love yapp dummy i love yapp i love
yapp i love yapp yapp yapp yapp are your arms okay now yeah
i'm goo i'm goo I'm goo.
I'm ectoplasm.
The impact.
But, so the last thing that I wrote before, I think I
mentioned this on the karaoke stream, but Disney was a 16
hour ordeal, which was just, I goo.
It was, it was the longest, it was so, so long we were like
at this park forever and ever um that's wild i'm hey you
gotta get your money's worth you know i don't go to disney
in america like ever because it's so expensive it costs more
time than money at this point it was it's so it's
ridiculously expensive oh my gosh It's terrible, honestly.
Like, there's memes that it is cheaper to fly to Japan and
go to Disney in Japan than it is to go to Disney in the
States for a couple of days.
Happy Boxing Day, boss!
Happy Boxing Day, Turner!
Thank you so much for the pink, thank you!
Sounds about Roy.
And honestly, I would say Disney in Japan is way better.
Actually, I would even say go to Universal in Japan.
It's even better.
It's tough.
But, you know, I only went for dinosaur.
So I prefer Space Mountain in Disneyland Paris.
It's very similar to Rock and Roller Coaster.
Oh, really?
Wait.
So does it go upside down and stuff too?
Because I remember Rock and Roller Coaster has like
inversions and stuff where Space Mountain does not usually.
Have you ever been to Fujiqu?
Absolutely, I love Fujiqu!
I love Fujiqu.
Yeah.
Do you have a theme park tier list?
Honestly, I've been...
Thank you!
I've been wanting to do...
That's why I've kind of been going to more theme parks
recently, because I've been trying to, like...
Not...
I mean, like, I consider myself...
a bit of a like a theme park otaku so i've been really you
know and i watch a lot of videos and stuff but i i don't go
out so much so um i've been trying to expand in my my
everything to be like oh yeah i've been to this park and
here's my pros and cons and such so yeah do you offer What
is that?
Wait, offer...
Nasty Scrooge.
Tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick hauntings.
Oh, like the ghost of Christmas past and future and present?
Oh!
I'm the ghost of Christmas stupid.
Ever been to Cedar Point?
No!
I want to go, though.
I want to go so bad.
Hope you can haunt Orlando again for Epic.
Yeah, I want to go to Epic so bad.
That's an idea for the Minto Thon, the theme park tier list.
I'm very specific about things I like, though.
I like, I don't prefer, or rather, roller coasters with,
like, a lot of loops and corkscrews.
stuff i don't really care about i like i like rides with big
drops i like the big i like i like getting good air time
hope you had a good christmas and glad to hear you feeling
better thank you thank you thank you favorite theme park
probably fujikyu
goliath would be a fun one for you oh i think uh i think
There's a ride at SeaWorld called, um, what was it called?
It's the shark one.
But I'm pretty sure it has the same exact track as Goliath.
Because I've seen, I've seen, like, videos of Goliath.
And I, and I'm pretty sure.
A Mako!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, Mako, Mako.
I brought my Mickey plush to ride wide.
Oh, I bought my Mickey plush to wide.
the sueso after Hormat.
It's super fun.
I want to ride Stardust Racer so bad.
Oh, ain't there.
The last time I went to Disney was probably close to 20
years ago with a girl I was dating.
We got into an argument and left two hours after getting
there.
That reminds me of the last time I was the last time I went
to a theme park in when I was a wee little baby.
uh i so it's kind of strange like i did not have enough
spiritual power to possess like an adult you know so i had
to possess a kid and um i went to go ride uh this was this
was universal i went to go ride dr doom's uh drop tower you
know and i went on it and the first time uh the people I was
with, they were able to distract the person from checking my
height.
And I was like, that was so fun!
I'm gonna go on it again.
And so I went on it again, they were like, um, we need to
measure your height.
And I had on Healy's, you guys.
To give myself an extra height advantage.
And they checked my height the second time!
And they were like, nah.
You're too small i was like i i remember kicking and
screaming being so sad no this is not a hot dog moment i was
kicking and screaming so sad i couldn't ride it and my mom
was like do you want to ride spider-man one last time and i
was like no get me out of here
and so that was my last experience i'm i'm like healing some
childhood traumas by going back to these parks a little bit.
Baby Corey, thank you so much for the fun!
I did hi dog!
You know the action park re-debut is Mountain Creek Water
Park.
Maybe you can rate- Oh boy.
Sorry to hear about your 22-
And I can ride every ride I want to now!
I can!
depends on who you possess right well i mean yeah but like
also i'm i'm i'm a more i'm a mature ghost i have much
spiritual energy i could do whatever i want i mean i show up
for you guys all the time huh do you know they go the ghost
of christmas awkward can you ask them to stop making my
uncle make a scene on christmas My sister My sister
yesterday She was like The topic of 6-7 came up And my niece
She was like She was like I love rage baiting Those were her
words verbatim And she kept talking about how she would rage
bait my mom with 6-7 And my sister very seriously Was just
like My sister very seriously was like I think I know where
six seven came from my mom was like where where from and my
sister goes why was six afraid of seven seven eight nine and
then she like looked around at the table like ah
I was like yeah that's a really old joke I just want to let
you know that I recently got an MGS because of you I've
never realized I've been missing out on such cinema until
recently I want to say thank you also I hope you had a
wonderful Christmas Bo for my son thank you thank you so
much wonderful I hope you had a wonderful Christmas too she
thought she was breaking new ground she really did
It was just, she was so excited to say it.
And I was like, I think that joke's been, I don't know, I
think it's been around longer.
But, yeah, it was kind of silly.
But, oh, shall we play a game?
Shall we play the easy delivery code?
I hope Nisbu isn't a dragoon with all that rage bait.
Toho and Serpent Eater's great.
Got him on loop.
Oh, Seymour, thank you!
Yeah, I also...
I've been doing so much recently.
I also...
I am in a Toho Yaro beat single.
And I was in a Baka Mitai tribute album by...
By Silver Gunner.
I get to do Christmas with extended folks on Sunday.
I have nephews actually totally banned from Seymour.
seven because their parents can't take it anymore are we
well are we delivering babies from all the eyeball pregnant
well how why is it pregnant why why why i got the merch i
ordered when you put them out there got a nice mouse pad of
you too thank you i am the ghost of downloads past you may
have cleared your browser history but when was the last time
you checked your downloads folder i could i got i've got i
cleaned it out not too long ago
Welcome to Easy Call.
Have an easy day.
We're delivering packages today, everybody.
And it seems easy.
Nice.
Why do you have to clean it out?
Because I save everything to download.
Do you guys...
I'll save everything to download.
I think even files that I use on the regular are saved to
download.
Make a delivery, that's my goal.
Side goal.
I save everything the downloads, and then I forget to
organize it later.
Oh, I got another...
I got another delivery!
Easy eats.
Easy flowers.
Everything is easy.
How do I drive this thing?
Uh, wait, what's my mail?
Camera.
Camera.txt.
Change your driving view.
Okay.
Jobs.
To start working, EasyCoD delivery drivers must select and
confirm jobs using the job selection software.
Payment will be provided upon verification of completed
deliveries.
Congrats.
Congratulations.
We at EasyCo are pleased to inform you that you have been
hired as a valued EasyCoD delivery driver.
Is this a strand game?
That stranding looks different than I remember it.
What the heck?
A friend of mine made this game.
Have fun.
No way!
Thank you, Index!
Happy holidays, everyone.
Happy holidays.
You are now responsible for delivering important easy coal
merchandise to and from the local businesses in...
Interprofit sector.
Have an easy day!
How do I get out of here?
Wait, I think I have to select a job, right?
So we're going to easy eats.
Or...
Easy flowers.
This one pays more.
Pick up from easy flowers.
Find the lit-up storefront.
I'm driving?
Welcome to Mountain Town.
Uh...
I don't see like a...
Like a...
Oh!
Beep!
Look at this!
I'm too cute!
Minchidi.
This guy has seen some things.
Nah, I'm Minto.
Oh, no.
New guy.
I guess you're doing the deliveries now.
I'm Ada.
I'm not talking very well these days.
Oh my gosh, you guys.
My mom invited a friend over yesterday and you wouldn't know
what her name is.
Eva.
I was like, don't tell me that.
Don't say your name is Eva.
That can't be a real person name.
It can't be.
I'm not talking very well these days.
Oh, pick up the payload.
Goodbye.
Nobody took my truck, right?
Okay.
It's so tiny.
Alright.
Check info.
Look for the icon.
Deliver the package to Upton.
I don't think this is a horror game.
Oh!
Up!
What do I do?
Help me!
package.
Oh my gosh, it really is.
Oh, geez.
Accidents happen.
Easy code value is efficiency over quality.
Dropping part of a package will not affect your... Oh, good.
However, recovering a package takes time.
Dropping an entire package will result in a reduced tip.
Have an easy day.
Oh, is it starting to get cold?
Do you see, like, my vision?
Oh, I see the icon.
There's nobody else on the street.
Let's get this.
Oh!
Boy, do you look at that.
Wait, do I place it here?
How's the audio, by the way?
A little loud?
Might not be able to stay out long.
Yeah.
Oh, get in.
Let's see.
What else do we got?
We got some goals?
Which we did.
Sss.
Yeah.
It's okay if some of the payload breaks.
I did.
Definitely had that happen.
159.
Oh, easy flowers again.
Let's do it.
I know where they are.
Okay.
How do I...
Beep.
Let's check this out.
Oh, yeah.
Merry belated Christmas, Meantau.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Jerk.
Back it up, back it up, back it up, back it up, back it up.
Hey there, new guy.
It looks like your map is missing some data.
I can fix it for you, but I'll need something in return.
Buy me an energy drink from the vending machine over there,
and we'll call it even.
I heard that K trucks will soon be legal in U.S.
and Suzuki is going to push some new model.
Starting at, like, 7K?
It'd be so cool.
I heard, though, that K trucks, like, do not.
They don't.
They are not up to the standard of...
They will be crushed.
They are very tiny, as much as I would love that.
They are so...
They are, like, they become an accordion.
Unfortunately.
I don't know if it'll happen.
Hope you had a Merry Christmas, man.
You too, John.
We better.
Welcome back.
Thank you.
What was I grabbing?
Greetings.
Nice to see you again.
It's been a while since I've spoken to someone new.
Such a nice soul.
Okay, this time I won't break your package.
I promise.
Promise, promise, promise, promise.
Close.
Look at that.
Wait, where's our vending machine?
I wish I could move the camera around some more.
I can't see where the vending machine is.
And it's getting cold.
Give me the fire!
Over defrosting?
Where is it?
Buy an energy drink from the vending machine and bring it to
the dog.
You might have to take another delivery.
It is cozy.
This game is so cozy so...
Oh.
I see.
That's how you change the...
Beep.
Oh, beep.
Oh, uh, beep.
Beep.
I wonder, though, if I can look around with this.
to see okay let's just keep going
nice open interact place yeah I'm so efficient have an easy
day I like this camera angle better oh wait I see it right
here Italy happy birthday from a fellow fellow tell me happy
birthday Yay!
Happy, happy birthday!
Oh, man.
That cost money.
Wait, can I go in here?
Oh, this is easy eats.
I'm glad no one else uses this road, for real, huh?
Hey, hey.
It wouldn't let me say hag.
YouTube hates hags.
Oh.
I just ran myself over.
Hello!
Buy me an energy drink.
I did, I did!
Wait, I did though.
I didn't get it.
Wait, what do you mean I didn't get it?
Oh, I had to take it?
Uh oh.
I hope nobody steals my drink.
Nobody!
Nobody better steal my drink!
I paid good money for that!
Grab it.
Take it.
Okay.
Wide turn.
Let's go.
Kick.
Huh.
Alright.
Hello.
Mind the gas tank.
I've been looking at it.
A deal is a deal.
There you go.
What are you fixing for me?
data.
Actually, keep the drink.
You'll need it.
You'll have to maintain your energy to take on heavy
deliveries.
The name is MK, by the way.
I used to do maintenance for Easy Coal.
You should meet me at my cabin in Snowy Peaks for a cup of
coffee.
It's not too far from here.
Just north of up the...
Rocket fuel.
L1 is inventory.
Oh, thank you!
Though, you'll need to figure out how to clear the
roadblock.
I think a lighter will do the trick.
A lighter Oh, we're getting a lighter.
What is this?
Map.
We at Easy Co-op determined that the bus delivery drivers
are those who have learned the layout of their assigned
profit sector.
As a result, we will not be providing any navigational aid.
I just started!
Buy a lighter from the depot.
You'll have to earn some more money first.
Alright.
Time to take on some jobs.
jobs.
Oh, $15!
$15!
$20!
Where are we?
We can do this.
Right?
Pick up from Easy Pizza.
Okay.
Alright.
Easy now.
Yeah.
Okay.
Where do I go, though?
It did say no Elp, huh?
Why don't I have a map at all?
Pizza.
Alright, and we might have to...
It's not fuel.
I guess so.
Yeah, it is.
Stop and look both ways.
Oops, sorry, that's the wrong...
I pressed go instead of stop.
Where am I?
Head to Easton.
If I...
I...
I'm an uproar.
I need to go downtown.
So this would be where?
Wait, let's see what the sign says.
Too western.
Too eastern.
Upton.
Typical everyone knows ghosts are bad drivers.
That's not true at all!
Oh, I see myself!
I see myself!
Oh, we just need to go down this road and we'll go to
eventually.
A fork.
Ooh, ooh.
Look both ways, including down.
Taco Thomas, are you?
Welcome back, thank you.
Oh my gosh, thank you so much for the taco soup.
Merry Christmas, Minky.
I'll be at a good one.
You too!
What's this?
I could hear my car.
It's kind of cute.
Is this like a radio station?
Oh, anybody here?
What's that dude?
I'm getting every station now.
All right, all right.
Oh, and there's times.
I just realized it's almost five people.
Can you play Oide Masay from the radio tower?
Bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing.
Driving while haunting.
Hey, hey, hey.
That's my, that's my normal state, all right?
Oh my god.
Durifto!
Chupacabura, chupacabu.
Merry Christmas, Merry Christmas!
Shmake, thank you!
Wait, let's see where we're at.
at.
Oh, wait.
Oh, that's my cursor.
I thought that's where I was.
Okay.
We gotta keep going still, though.
This is that bridge right there.
Hit the birds.
Deer.
Watch for deer.
So we're about, like, over here.
Okay.
We're gonna hit a west... Oh, my gosh.
There's not a gas until eastern.
That's crazy.
Am I gonna be okay?
Maybe.
Oh,
the lift, the...
Oh, oh, I know how to drift.
I know how to drift.
Like that.
We won't run out of gas!
Actually, but there was no other gas station.
What do I do?
I am low on gas, but what do I do?
There was no other gas station.
There's only gas station here.
In Easton.
I have to get all the way through to get there.
Where am I?
I'm in a city.
I'm somewhere.
I think this is like a...
Oh, we're in Weston.
Okay.
Your gas is almost full.
It's a little arrow to the right of F.
No, I definitely...
Wait, is it not the thing that's blinking right now?
What is that then?
The blinking one is energy.
My energy?
Oh, I just got a thing about energy.
Oh, I see.
All EasyCo drivers are expected to maintain peak operational
efficiency.
EasyCo delivery drivers are only authorized to purchase easy
energy drinks from the official EasyCo Easy Energy vending
machine.
Low energy may result in lower body temperatures, so be
careful of the cold.
Have an easy day.
Ah, I see.
Oh, also, if I press L1.
That shows me the map.
Okay, that's really easy then.
Easy.
Let's go get the lighter.
Wait, I can't afford the lighter.
Just kidding.
Let's go to Easton.
One here with the Minkee.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
You're fine.
It's a real quick babe.
It's getting dark though, isn't it?
It's kind of spooky.
wait where am i i think i'm here so if i turn here
to eastern yeah mary christler did you guys see that thing
that was like if you say mary christler i'm low energy oh
i'm so tired l1 inventory energy drink wait how do i eat it
eat it Did I get it?
Wait, what's happening?
Oh god, wait, enter the bar?
Did I...
So I used it.
Eat the can, too.
That was close.
Wait, but it's not used.
How do I use it?
Ow!
There we go.
empty can hello boy I heard you're new I'm fives did you
meet my twin 6-0 yet if 6-0 asks if you want to make some
money just run away wait but I want to make some money
what's that right there
so we had to find more vending machines
what's this place a cafe easy cafe it's a scam what are
these MLM guess in this town you need to order a pizza a day
in advance because you'll starve if you're overweight hey
I'm doing my best coffee is 475 happy holidays Minto happy
holidays fancy seeing you here I heard we had a different
delivery driver but i didn't know you'd be so handsome i'm
getting flirted with you can call me fit or call me the love
of your life if it's really your choice love watching you
walk away this one's for you
that's so smooth
all right to east my tailgate is open Oh, oops.
Oh, my car is running away.
Uh-oh.
We're fine.
Everything's chill.
To Eastern.
Tunnel to fishing.
Is that what that is there?
Hmm.
Oh!
A vending machine.
I need to stop getting out of my car before...
I have no body!
Before...
What's the word?
Breaking?
So where is...
Oh, it's right behind the gas station.
Oh, free one!
Oh, I didn't take the drink.
again.
Thank you.
I hope no one's behind me.
Take my drink.
There we go.
So it's like right...
I think I can go through here.
Yeah, the pizza!
the pizza I have no many famous jazz club singer hey you
know how to drive snapper call me foreman what I wouldn't
give for a day out fishing no one to bother me that's a
pretty someone's having the craziest party of their lives
I can't get in.
So where am I taking this bad boy?
All the way back to Weston?
No, no.
Wait.
Uh-oh.
The pizza can still fall out.
Pick it up.
Place it.
Close it.
Okay.
Nice and easy now, folks.
Alright, alright.
We did not offer same-day delivery, by the way.
So it's fine.
Oh.
If I keep breaking fast, it'll, you know.
Alright.
Here we go.
Wait.
Shoot.
Beep.
Wait, where did my pizza go?
Okay, it was...
already eaten by the rats in the city.
Pizza for breakfast everybody enjoys.
Everybody enjoys that.
This seriously, like...
This is awesome service.
That's... Actually, this is the exact time that they asked
for it to be delivered.
They said, I need my pizza at 3 a.m.
And I'm even delivering early.
Oops.
Sorry, I got a little, um...
Beep, beep, beep.
It's gone.
Okay, I got a little... It's so icy, you guys.
It's so icy!
I couldn't help it.
Where is it now?
I don't know where we are.
I think I have to just keep going over here.
They said that if I lose it, it's fine.
And trust me, I'm losing it.
What does this one say?
To east.
To upton.
Where does the road to the left go?
Wait, is this not where I need to deliver this?
Actually?
No tip.
Oh, I'm going backwards.
Oopsie.
Oops.
I don't need to reset!
I don't need to reset.
Don't tell me I need to reset.
I don't need to.
I have all-wheel drive.
Don't you know you're supposed to drive like you got a glass
of water on the dashboard in wintery conditions?
I've never heard that before.
Same day delivery pizza.
Now I'm envisioning a dystopian future where you can't get
pizza without prime membership.
Oh, God.
Don't say that.
Wait.
I'm so confused.
Do I need to go this way?
For the pizza?
Let's try it.
Oh, we are close.
We are close.
Oh, yes, yes, yes.
Okay, okay.
And it's fine.
We're not losing a single thing.
Yep.
Nice.
Take that out and place that down.
Nope.
Take it.
And place it.
Uh, oh gosh, wait.
I'm starting to get cold.
Wait, place it.
Ah, uh, oh, wait.
Oh god, get in my car!
Scary!
I gotta warm up a little bit.
Okay.
All right.
My energy is too low.
Wait, no.
I need to get an energy drink.
Use.
Okay.
You can drink inside places.
I think I have to move my car a little bit though.
Oops.
Alright, like right there.
Right there.
Alright.
Alright, alright.
Get it.
Grab it.
Place it.
Oh, there we go!
Yippee!
All right, let's go inside the bar.
New delivery guy.
I'm 6-0.
Listen, I have an investment opportunity that'll knock your
socks off.
Let me just think of it.
Oh, all right.
Wait, so what was it?
5-0 and 6-0?
All right, all right.
Get in.
Okay, let's buy some more.
I just need How do I grab it?
Oh, like Take... Ah!
I see Can I also kick?
No, just buy some more Get in?
Alright, let's Get another job
Western, Upton, Easton, Upton This one is so much Avani!
Easy flowers!
Oh, because it's Upton to Easton I think we could do the the
eastern one because that should cover us for the lighter I
think yeah yeah yeah that'll cover us for the lighter pick
up from bar okay we know where to go
I saw that you can buy the soundtrack for this game on steam
I think it might be worth looking into why am I so cold why
don't I put on pants you know
why don't I do that
Whoa!
That was kind of sick.
Van pants.
What is this?
Strike witches?
I hate pants.
Oi!
I saw you speaking with MK the other day.
MK and Seb used to be inseparable, and I hope they're doing
okay.
Bit mysterious, that guy.
Let's go.
Oh, these ones definitely won't fall out at all.
These ones won't be a beer o'clock, baby.
Then it's 6.30 a.m.
Good morning, Minto.
No wonder where I'm delivering these two.
Do you think I'm invited?
Just drive safely.
I think you jinxed me!
Pick up the payload!
I can still grab it!
Timing!
You jinxed me for real!
Oh wait, don't do that, don't do that, don't do that, don't
do that, don't do that.
Don't forget your seatbelt!
Yep.
Beer and mint don't mix.
I can't drink.
Well, I can.
I just don't.
So, you know.
Oh, right here?
Wait, is it pizza?
Pizza ordered beer?
Recovery is one.
Don't tell me that.
Wait, so how much?
Wait, oh, I have enough money!
Okay.
Should we do anymore?
East and Weston.
Another Easton, Upden, Easton.
Weston, Upden.
We could do another Easton, Weston one.
Because we're in Easton right now.
And we had to go to Weston anyway, so start drop.
Pick up from Paw and show up.
Lighter was 29?
Wait.
I thought it was...
Oh, it is 29.
You're right.
It was 21.
You may have observed the beautiful weather and landscapes
of Interprofit Sector.
Just a friendly reminder that we encourage our delivery
drivers to always stay in or close to their assigned easy
code delivery vehicle in order to maintain optimal
operational efficiency.
He's 29.
Wait, how much do I have?
27.
Oh, well, this will still get us.
It'll be kind of giddy-giddy, but
Wait, where is the pine shop?
Oh, I have to make a loopy loop.
Have an easy day.
What's that red light over there?
What is that?
Oh, it's a tower.
Curious.
So many loops.
Loops.
Is it here?
Oh.
Yes, indeedy.
Easy auto.
Wait, do I have to fix my car?
You seem familiar.
Do I know you?
I'm Cece.
What's really in these deliveries?
I ought to check, but that's exactly what they'd want me to
do.
There's a bunch of plants.
Cece.
Oh.
Look at that.
Your car needs gas soon, does it?
Let's see.
Close.
Okay, then.
No, it doesn't.
I need...
Actually, I'm gonna get out.
And I'm gonna have my energy drink.
Low energy.
There we go.
Go away.
Okay, there we go.
Yeah, my body needs energy.
But the fuel is pretty...
Actually, it's very generous, it seems.
I guess because there's...
Only one place the fuel.
Don't worry about it.
Don't worry your pretty little head about it.
It would have fallen out, no matter what I did.
I could have driven, like...
Like there was a baby in the back.
And it would have fallen out.
Oh, there.
The bar is ordering everything, huh?
Grab it.
Place it.
See, no recovery is needed.
And we're...
We got it!
VB would not approve.
What?
Uh...
here is the lighter, I suppose.
Over yonder.
Over
here.
Did I miss it?
Over there?
Yo, girl.
I wish I could zoom in.
This kind of animal crossing with a hint of Santa Hill snow.
I don't know.
Underwear!
I'm actually confused.
Where is that?
I don't want to be wasting my gas.
Maybe it's in the next town over and I just...
Is it up left?
Oh wait, uh, not bad.
Hmm, I don't know.
Is up dog.
What's up dog?
Maybe we're in the depot.
Oh, I see.
Wait.
Oh, we weren't...
Oh, that's the tunnel.
Okay, okay, okay.
Ugh.
I've been having so many issues with my eyes lately, you
guys.
Oh my gosh, today?
I had my first ever ocular migraine.
It was kind of wild.
i couldn't see any oh i forgot to take it again my bad take
it there we go it was so weird i've never had one before
easy depot maybe in here yeah it was so scary
hello um i'm fortito not that it matters and you keep a
secret?
I just met you.
I don't even care.
I'm hopelessly in love with Ellie at the bakery.
Oh my gosh, you know what you should do?
You should invite her to the Mint Phantom Jazz 3D Live show
on February 13th at the Peppermint Club.
It would be such a great date!
But they don't even know I exist.
I'll just be here.
Talk, coffee powder, duct tape, tea bags, firewood, energy
drink.
Wait, but where is the, uh, the lighter?
Lighter.
Sorry.
I'm, okay, nope.
Yeah, yeah.
Can I buy it, please?
That will cost $29.98.
Thank you.
I'll just be here.
All right.
Cabin in Snowy Peaks.
That is the most expensive lighter ever.
Holy moly.
Tell her to use code Boomer.
So where are we going?
Visit the cabin in Snowy Peaks.
Try an intercity delivery on the way.
Wow.
Backseating me much.
What was...
Oh.
Oh, cool.
I was gonna say, what is cam.exe?
Densetsu.exe?
Wait, how do I get out of cam.exe?
Uh, good lighters are expen.
Um, wait, how do I get out of cam.exe?
Oh, there we go.
Okay.
We're fine.
Everything's cool.
Let's...
Oh, snowy peaks!
Don't know where this is.
One kilogram, but it's so much money.
For how small it is.
Let's do that one.
Oh,
I pick it up right here.
Pick up from bar.
Okay, easy.
Yeah, there's headlights apparently.
Hat dog!
I've been getting ocular migraines since my teens.
You have my sympathies.
Just using one eye can help a little.
Thank you.
Yeah, it was really weird because it was like, I was like, I
couldn't read any text and everything was like fuzzy.
Like a fuzzy, it was like a fuzzy ring.
I was like, whoa, this is weird.
The truck has no backseat.
Backseating is therefore impossible.
Ah, my watch.
It's bar over here, right?
Yeah.
Give me an eye patch.
I'm ready to cosplay.
Sometimes I try to talk to the birds.
They ignore me every time.
Must have been personal.
Are you gonna give me your delivery or...
Wait, what?
Oh, must... wait.
Why does it... Like, there's an arrow over here pointing to
these.
Wrong bar.
Which bar is it?
This is bar.
Other bar.
Where, uh, his brother's at?
Is it one over here?
You're telling me you don't already own an eye patch?
Well, you know, just like, uh...
One of professional grade.
is all i'm saying wait is this the bar this is the bar
factory
hello you hear me out imagine a machine could do what you're
doing but somehow worse with a larger margin of error and it
costs decades of environmental decline where's that what's
the pit wait what's the payload.
Just that?
Oh, it's a single drink.
Surely this will be fine, everybody.
I'm gonna use my drink first.
Oh.
Hold on.
Imagine.
Alright, alright, alright.
No sleeping on our watch.
We are nice and bright and awake.
It's only 6 p.m.
Alright, so we're going all the way to the in snowy peaks.
There's the bakery.
Procular migraines, I found sometimes I can leave it by
putting on sunglasses.
Oh, I just closed my eyes and forgot about it.
I said, no, not today, maybe.
Reading about, apparently it's because blood...
Well, I don't have blood, though.
Must be different for ghosts.
Okay.
crash don't crash oh my god do you see the bottle there oh
my god oh my god oh my god that's why it's such a difficult
this is the toughest delivery any delivery person has had to
make ever i won't crash i won't crash
not on my watch i am going really fast up these hills though
at least the beer is still It ain't cold.
Right.
I mean, oh, why is it swinging around like that?
You're making me nervous.
Then slow down.
I don't know how to...
Break is not in my middle name.
My name is Mint Go Faster Phantom.
It's literally...
In my DNA.
Gas, gas, gas, gas, gas, gas.
No cup holders.
Yeah, why didn't we put this in the front with us, actually?
We made it.
Welcome to Upton.
Mint floor at Phantom.
It's over this way, right?
Tunnel to snowy peaks.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I just light this on fire?
Yeah.
Why was it sealed?
Who did this?
Why am I causing arson?
Mint's metal name is Crash, not Break.
Wait.
No!
I was thinking Crash Bandicoot.
Speed freak phantom.
I think I can go.
Oh.
think I could have gone.
Wait.
Uh, guys, back up.
It's almost gone.
There we go.
On the road again.
Truly the PS1 experience.
Enter snowy peaks.
What just was that?
Ooh, it's snowy for sure.
It's really chilly up in here.
Ooh, they're like, watch the road, watch the road.
If ectoplasm is not ghost blood, then what fluid is it?
Oh my god.
They're trying to...
Like...
Sabotage me.
Um...
Well, what do you consider goo?
All-wheel drive, all-wheel drive?
What would goo be to you?
Wait, here?
Or down there?
Welcome to Snowy Peaks.
To Muntin.
Winton.
Oh, here.
Nerd laundry.
Thank you so much, reload.
Thank you.
Have an easy day.
Can I have a coffee?
Welcome.
It's been a while since someone else was over.
Sorry about the mess.
Here is promised.
Coffee is a much better energy source than energy drinks.
It takes some effort to prepare, but will last you a lot
longer.
Besides, anything good in life takes a little effort.
So true.
Guys, it's MK, definitely not KK.
You remind me of my good friend Seb.
They liked coffee, too.
Me, though, I'm more of a tea dog.
I'm rambling.
To brew your own coffee, you'll need a cooking pot.
There's one for sale here at the depot.
Cooking pot.
But you're free to use mine anytime.
Yeah.
Why don't you brew yourself with more coffee before you go?
Anyways, a word of warning.
Snowy peaks has treacherous, uneven terrain.
You'll need snow tires!
You can purchase some at Easy Auto down the road.
Oh, that was far, though, no?
Good luck out there.
Wait, that was kind of far, no?
Wait, how do I brew?
Cook.
I'm cooking.
Oh, my gosh.
Breaking bad.
I'm cooking.
Yeah, science.
Can I burn it?
No.
I'm drinking?
That's the strong stuff.
Put it away?
Okay.
We got three things of coffee.
Okay, awesome.
Oh, okay.
Just the same audio.
Or same...
dialogue so where are we heading baby our goals cooking pot
brew the coffee which we did snow tires i think snow tires
is pretty important let's see what jobs we got right now
winton muntin winton muntin winton muntin like how they use
resident evil one camera angles with Animal Crossing
aesthetics set to PS1 graphics.
Is the game such as...
It does feel spooky, no?
Winton Month Easy Eats.
Snow Tires.
Pick up.
Fuel pick...
Oh, there's fuel there, too.
So we're going to...
Winton?
Is that where we're going?
Winton.
It feels...
It's very cozy and like...
It's got like an uneasy vibe about it.
Winton
Mountain Cause is spooky Yeah, I'm vibing You guys vibing?
Whoa!
Mountain?
These guys need To plow the roads What is going on here?
Oh, Easy Auto.
Wait, is it?
Where was I picking?
Oh, I was picking up From Easy Eats, so where is that?
Oh,
next to fuel.
So we're here.
Snow tires.
Oh, we need to have a far ways to go.
Oh, we survived.
We're just vibing.
We're in Phantom Channel, whatever.
Uh-oh.
Yeah.
I can't afford the...
Oh, I can't afford the tires.
I'm kidding.
I didn't think I could afford them
Easy auto
Hey, Seb That's not my name It's me, Reed I saw you just the
other day Wait, I'm not Seb Do we look like Seb?
Our little K truck is still struggling Man, I keep
forgetting things Who are you again?
Sorry Who were you again?
Excuse me, sir.
Oh, we read all this.
Oh, snow tires.
That will cost $29.98.
Okay.
We are broke.
Your upgrade will be installed right away.
All set.
Awesome.
All right.
We got our goals.
So now we have to purchase the cooking pot from the depot
when snowy peaks.
Coffee is more cost-effective than energy drinks.
I like the sound of that.
I'll give it a few bucks.
Uh, MK!
Right on, you got yourself some snow tires.
You'll have no problem driving in snowy peaks now.
I'll be heading to fishing town soon.
Through the tunnel in Easton.
There's something I could really use your help with.
They won't let me drink more monster energy.
Probably for the best.
Good luck out there.
Fishing town, eh?
Let me get a couple more bucks.
Are we going to be cruising through here now?
Oh my gosh, did you guys see us tackle that?
That was so easy.
Oh my gosh, I'm like so good at driving now.
Let's go.
Meow.
Where am I going?
Upper Lopton.
Oh, I see.
Okay.
Upper mountain.
Don't jinx it.
I would never.
Where am I going?
At least our car doesn't break.
I like how it says the tailgate is open.
I have no delivery.
We're fine.
Look at us.
Sick.
Wait.
Where am I?
I?
pickup.
Is it here?
Can I go in here?
Looks kind of spooky, no?
Anybody home?
Oh, I can't go in.
It does indeed, it does indeed belong to somebody.
That is not me.
Nice, nice, didn't I?
It's a good thing we had just in money for the for the what
the the tires huh maybe i'm pretty good at this game how how
far are we going here whoa whoa
does matter for ghosts to haunt a house i you know like i'm
not one to haunt a place where another ghost is i'm i'm
pretty territorial like that i don't want to be sharing a
space in all roommates and all who's living up here where
are we picking it up from where am I
here?
no boo mates no hey mate, welcome, I'm Theo how have things
been so far looks like you're doing great the more time you
spend with the locals I'm sure the more they'll like you.
It looks...
There was like a fuel area.
A gas station.
Is this 6-0?
Oi!
Having nothing in the world but dreary weather and trees
empties your soul.
But maybe it's not so empty when you know a few people in
it.
I need my delivery.
Where is it?
7-0, 8-0, 9-0, 10-0.
I know how to count, too.
I'm lost.
There's no fuel here.
Bingo!
Is this Neimo?
Better graphics makes for less spooky.
I agree.
You're at the top of Muntin.
I went to Muntin, not Winton!
I thought I followed the signs to Winton.
Or maybe I read wrong.
Oh my gosh, wait, I just went the entirely wrong way.
Uh-oh.
Wait.
Oh, no.
No!
Here I was thinking I was making great time.
Oh my gosh.
At least I got my tires.
Oh, we're fine.
Everything's cool.
This is such a drive even.
I'm worried about our gas.
But gas seems to last.
Shortcut?
We're fine.
Company car, so I don't have to pay for it.
I didn't know that the car could set on fire.
There's all physics in this.
Wait, am I going the right way?
Yes.
Fall damage, I mean.
Not physics.
My bad.
Okay.
We're okay.
Come on.
There we go.
No, I don't need to reset.
Who do you think I am?
I'm Mint Never Punished Phantom.
I can get out of anything!
Oh.
Yes.
Nice.
Someone else will need that light.
They should fix it, probably.
I'm going...
That's why I'm going to Winton, because I know...
never failton phantom never punished
to win 10 to win 10 to win 10 don't say minus two that was
good you guys are haters you're all haters
tunnel to mountain town what's he oh this is okay okay this
is the cabin
where we can make coffee okay this way hate is a strong word
hate and love are opposites of the same coin okay I'm not
even touching the wheel all right
my bad we're fine here
hate super chat no oh my gosh are you like hate watching me
right now.
Gosh, I can't stand this ghost.
She just says the stupidest stuff all the time.
Oh, here it is, the Uber Eats.
The Eats.
Hello.
I'm gonna have to grab dinner soon for myself.
Howdy, Whippersnapper.
Japers.
You look like the spitting image of Seb.
The spitting image, I say.
But no one listens to old toey.
Don't let them work you too hard.
Thank you.
Actually, I'm going to drink a coffee.
Alright, nice.
Okay.
Take that.
Oh.
And close it.
You think we're good on fuel?
Oh, I have no money.
Oops.
So we must be good on.
We will be good on fuel.
Like our life depends on.
so I was thinking oh we probably like look like Seb because
everybody keeps mistaking us for him interesting interesting
are we like little are we a clone they're a fun you should
be able to do another delivery or so okay cool feel should
be fine it does I mean it lies a long time but I'm afraid
that it's gonna cost a bajillion dollars too because it
lasts so long you know oh oh oh my gosh safe okay to Monten
we're killing it guys we're killing it hate watching hate
super chatting hate membu shipping Hate member gifting.
Yeah, I get it.
I get it.
Guys, thank you.
Thank you for all your hate.
Hate everything.
Have an easy day.
What else we got?
What's all I got?
Oh, to buy the cooking pot.
At the depot.
And meet MK.
Okay.
in fishing town.
Let's do like a bunch of jobs here, then.
Well, these are all mountain town.
Oh my god!
Thank you for the bargain.
Thank you!
Holy cow!
This one is...
Oh!
Wait, 105.
We'll do this one.
Because it pays a lot.
But it's not heavy.
Easy Depot.
Wait, where?
Where is this?
Mountain town?
I have to go to...
It was just my birthday!
Before things have been pretty bad for me lately, therefore
I ask for a moment of awkward silence, preferably with the
icon town.
Orbital of Aquaman!
Happy birthday!
There we go.
I don't know where to go.
I'm confused.
Wait.
Winton.
Not Winton.
We go the other way.
This way, this way, this way, this way.
Here, on it.
Mountain Town.
It said Mountain Town, right?
Where am I?
I'm so confused.
I'm like here?
I guess I'll follow them.
Mountain Jam.
We're killing it.
Let's go.
Easy peasy.
Gliding like a champ.
Where was the pickup?
Pick up from snowy peaks.
Wait, what?
But then what's this say?
Oh.
Back it up.
Wait a second, though.
Okay.
It says...
Pick up from Easy Depot.
What is this?
Where am I?
Wait.
Huh?
I'll
go forward.
I'm back in Stoey Peaks?
Okay.
I think I just gotta go back this way.
I thought I just needed to keep reversing.
Back it up.
I think I need to go to...
When...
Ma...
Eh?
Why can't I go down on the map?
So this is Winton, but I...
The map confuses me so much.
And then we take the tunnel over here?
Have we not... have we been to Easy Depot, no?
Or not yet?
And Mint is considered one of the best VTuber drivers,
according to Homes!
Press A on map to drag.
Oh, thank you!
Oh, I see.
I kind of...
I think I get it now.
Okay.
I don't know why it was confusing me so much.
Maybe because I thought I had been there already.
But once we hit the...
This one.
Okay, here.
Oh, that's...
There it is.
Okay.
We graze that?
Danmak?
To
the left!
Take it back now, y'all.
Suddenly, MGS2 boss music.
Why is bar backwards?
Easy cafe right here.
What else could you ask for in a town?
Easy cafe, easy bar, you don't need anything else, huh?
Fantasy seeing you here.
Myth can drive very well.
Nav- I can navigate!
I can, I can!
You can deliver my package any day, if you know what I mean.
Get it?
Because you're the delivery driver?
Love watching you walk away.
Wait, where is...
Where's the package?
Oh, Easy Depot.
Just kidding.
I thought it was Easy Cafe.
I think it's up here.
There it is.
And the bakery.
I spoke to Ellie for hours yesterday.
I've never feared the future before because I had nothing to
look forward to.
Now that I do, meow, meow.
I'm a little friend, meow, meow.
Are you winning, Minto?
I just got back for my birthday dinner.
Rico!
Happy birthday!
Everybody's birthdays!
Crazy!
But I've decided that the unknown is what makes life
exciting.
Meow meow.
No!
Get out.
Close it.
Get him.
Wait, I kind of want to meet Ellie, though.
I'm assuming that all the cats are the same.
Oh.
Who are you?
They call me the crazy one.
Never taken a bite out of one of those packages.
Can't say I haven't.
Do you think they should teach dolphins how to read?
No.
Oh my gosh, I had to explain to someone recently how crazy
dolphins actually are.
Yeah, okay, great, good.
What's in this tea?
I'll try it.
it?
Wait, where'd my tea go?
Wait, where'd my... Oh, I didn't buy it, that's why.
Huh?
Oh, okay.
Dolphins are cool, but evil.
Yeah.
Okay, my tea.
Oh, it's dark out.
Alright, we're going to... Mountain Town.
Back it up.
back it up.
Alright, nice and easy.
Someone is desperate for these crates.
No!
Don't worry about it.
They'll get their crates as long as we have one.
We have them all!
Oh my gosh, as long as we have one!
A dolphin killed my father.
That's why I heavily invest in all fishing industry.
Cool.
Dolphins are crazy though.
We keep losing our...
signal.
Okay.
We're fine.
Everything's cool.
Everything's chill.
MGS boss lore.
It really is.
Mountain town.
I'm a mountain girl.
Wait, where is mountain town?
It's this way, no?
Mountain town.
Dolphins don't live up to human etiquette.
They have no moral.
Am I going to be okay on?
I guess we could always go to the other place.
I get more money.
We don't have to go all the way to Weston.
What is it, Weston?
Easton.
Oh, don't worry about it.
Don't worry, you're pretty little head.
Where am I going?
Delivery at the Weston!
Oh, where's Easton?
Wait, Weston.
West.
West on the...
We...
West on the left side.
E...
East on the right side.
Wee.
I think it's this way.
It's the easy news.
What are they saying?
Cannibalism!
A serial killer on the loose, lock all your doors!
A serial killer, specifically targeting package deliverers!
No way.
Couldn't be me.
This just in.
Guys, after this delivery, I'm going to go get some food for
myself if that's okay.
Was that a path that I saw on the right side of the road?
Curious.
Where am I?
I think I'm heading into Weston.
Yes, of course.
Thank you.
I got to take my medicine so I can...
I gotta take this medicine.
Wait, sorry, wait.
No, I meant to say I gotta eat some food so I can take this
medicine.
I gotta take
this medicine so I can take this medicine.
What's wrong with me?
Why can't I speak?
My brain!
Okay, we're...
We are...
Delivery!
I think this would be the eastern route.
So we can go this way.
Hey, bro, I heard you like medicine.
Alright, we're going downhill.
I'm not even on the...
Okay, nice, nice, nice.
Gas, gas, gas.
That's...
Oh, shoot.
We do need gas.
We need gas bad.
Time to go to Easton.
Grandma stuff.
Place it down.
Nice.
I hope I have enough money.
Are the meds pink too?
Pink gonna take our meds and we disappear.
You could never.
I think I'm too far gone.
Yeah, the package always regenerates.
rates, luckily.
Alright, I think this goes all straight to Easton, baby.
I already like meds, so I put meds in your meds.
Blah, blah, blah.
Alright, get some gas, and then we'll go to Fishtown.
Here.
Yes.
Shortcut.
Fuel.
Oh my gosh.
Hmm.
Welcome to Easy Fuel.
I'm Gus What a name my friend's new cat They just asked me
Gus I only sell fuel Have a terrible day That'll be fit Oh
no you guys I don't have enough money You don't have enough
funds Your tank will be partially filled for 40 Okay Oh they
just take all of your money Uh Okay I guess Okay I can't
even say how much I want.
It's not up to me.
It's not up to me, I guess.
Let's go back down.
Dinner time?
Yeah.
Once I go, shortcut.
Easy.
We're gonna have to take on some heavy duty jobs for the
next bit.
They took all...
Oh, gas took all my money.
I can't even afford anything.
Oh, you need the snow tires to get to the tunnel.
Probably.
You wanted fun?
Here you go, Minta.
Thank you, little...
Thank you.
Enter Fishing Town!
Oh.
I'll leave you here while I go get some food.
You can listen to Mk's delightful orchestra.
One second, I made some and then I was like, I think I want
more, so I'm gonna go get more.
I'm making more, one second.
Oh, Nimi, thank you for the bread.
Hello, naplings.
I'm getting some food real quick, so I'll just give you like
two seconds.
I'm back, sorry about that.
This game is so cute so far.
Alright, let's talk to WK.
Basically, we're making deliveries in this mysterious town.
Apparently, this used to be a bustling fishing village
before Iziko took over the Hydro Dam.
He blocked off the whole area for everyone, but employees
and locals.
here besides the ones owned by Easy Coal.
I actually need your help to infiltrate the dam!
There's some supplies there that we'll need.
Sneaking mission?
Wait.
Are we overthrowing Easy Coal?
WK is the only one without a job.
He gives you coffee instead of the energy drink, which Easy
Co says that you have to drink.
I think he's revolting.
I think him and Seb were going to work together, and then
they erased Seb's memories.
Because he was not being a good employee.
We'll bring him down.
MK.
MK, just flip it around.
Overthrow the company.
company.
To get your truck past a security gate, you'll need to
reactivate all local radio stations.
Ah, we did one!
It seems to be a strange failsafe implemented by the Easy
Co.
I recommend buying yourself a cooking pot while you're at
it.
I'll make the trip to the other side first.
I'll be waiting for you.
Good luck out there.
He misses Seb.
Wait, what if I drop down there?
Oh, see, yeah, we have one of them.
We have one of them.
Because I just clicked it on.
Okay, cool.
So, find and activate the radio, and we gotta do the cooking
pot.
Gone for 10 minutes?
What happened?
Not much.
I went and got food.
I forgot.
Let's, uh, let's have some coffee.
Oh, no, no, no, no.
Dang it, dang it, dang it.
Okay, there we go.
Nice, okay.
We only have one thing of coffee left, so...
Interesting, all right.
Where were the other radio towers then?
Hmm.
Where were they?
Huh.
Let's accept a job while I'm here.
Let's see.
Snowy Peaks.
We can do that one right here.
But this one looks like another single drink.
I guess we should also consider the length.
Like how far away it is.
Whoa!
What a hot second 64 bucks!
That would give us enough money.
Let's do it.
I haven't done any of it.
Oh, we have to pick it up in Weston.
What is this?
What is this one picked up at?
Oh, it's right here!
Okay, let's do this one.
Oh, it's easy flowers!
Easy, easy.
Okay.
140 kilograms?
I know.
It's kind of heavy.
It would probably use up all of our strength.
Easy Flowers is like what, right over here?
I'm a liar.
I think it's up there.
We have all wheel drive.
AKA snow tires.
East didn't rate...
Oh.
Light on fire?
Yeah, yeah.
Can I stay cool here?
Or warm here?
Wait, but this is kind of tricky.
No, I have to go all the way up.
But my energy is pretty good right now, so it might be good
to do it.
You think I could drive up it?
Can I get burned?
No.
But I have to get up here anyway.
Let's try it.
Okay.
Uh, are you good?
gonna stay on fire or what like come on oh my gosh oh nice
okay i did it here we go oh it's
getting cold i'm getting cold guys oh no oh no i need a
jacket oh no i need a jacket oh my gosh wait it's getting
really chilly wait if i die what happens to me oh my gosh
it's so high up dark.
Uh-oh.
Oh, my vision's getting a little rough, guys.
Where's the tower?
Oh, I'm stuck.
Ah!
I haven't
died yet before.
I couldn't see what was going on.
I had to burn the logs there.
I couldn't tell.
Do I keep walking?
Oh, I do.
I was, like, on the beach or something.
Wait, this is kind of spooky.
Someone's talking to me.
Is this a horror?
I don't...
Oh.
I don't know.
What happened to me?
Where am I?
We're back here.
Oh, Kairi.
Huh.
I still have my coffee, though.
Interesting.
Oh.
You think, though, that if I have my lighter, it'll keep me
warm?
I've got my love to keep me warm.
on fire my heart's desire but I want to overthrow easy coal
what do I care how much it may store I've got my love to
keep me warm let's see if this works it doesn't seem to have
like a limit so It's not Christmas anymore.
It's not about Christmas.
It's about winter.
Love to keep you warm.
It's about winter, no?
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
I don't want to die again.
Why don't I buy a sweater?
Oh, because I have zero dollars.
I've got no money.
Seek shelter.
I know, I know.
Oh, this does actually help, though.
Yeah, yeah, this is going to keep us warm, too.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, nice, nice, nice.
I'm just literally standing in it.
No frostbite for me.
Oh, it did actually help though, that's awesome.
All right, let me through.
My little tozies are so warm right now.
Husband, we spent, we are all out of money.
No, we can't buy coat.
Yay!
Turn on.
Sorry, hold on, give me a second to eat.
Alright.
We got this, guys.
Believe, believe, believe, believe, believe.
Believe.
Yes!
Yippee!
Okay, so we go pick up from the flowers.
Oh my gosh, I can't believe I just, like, found that flower.
by happens like by chance it's like wait this is auto what
are you pawn shop is
that the other side happenstance wait a second oh no I'm in
Easton I'm such a dummy dumb
I forgot that we were all the way over here.
I forgot.
I thought we were in Upton for some reason.
Okay, well, let's go to Upton then.
East then.
Maybe I am bad at directions.
Don't agree.
Actually, don't respond.
Don't say...
Don't...
Don't say we're not.
That's what we've been trying to tell you.
Don't say anything.
I don't stop for stop signs.
Don't...
Smile.
I don't want to see your smiles right now.
Don't at me.
Upton, Upton.
Is this a monster K-truck?
Monster truck?
I do think it's a K-truck, though.
You're like that at me?
You seem so, you're so mischievous.
I'm trying to contact you.
about your K-Trux extended warranty.
I don't need it.
I've never been in trouble in my whole afterlife.
What's Uptown?
Uptown girl.
She's been living in an Uptown world.
And she's a fantastic guy.
I don't know what to tell her and why.
Wait, so there's three, right?
Hold on.
So our goals, we have...
They might also have something to listen to.
We don't know where the third tower is.
Uptown Ghost!
Haunting around and always doing the most.
Going to abandoned places to scare them.
guys how's am I saying the words right all
she does is boo and cry she's an uptown ghost sounds about
right oh my bad we're fine light turned on right turned the
light on.
It's like, right, right, right here.
You might need the warranty.
Good greetings.
Have an easier day with easy predict.
What you will buy as soon as you want it.
Have, sorry, I don't know what came over me.
Oh my god, imagine have it.
Can't wait for the days when we have contacts and they
display ads over our eyes.
know to snowy peaks.
Okay.
We'll just keep doing snowy peak jobs because that's where
we gotta get the coffee anyway.
But we also need to find the the
the other tower.
If I were a radio tower, where would I be?
It seemed kind of mysterious.
Over...
Uh...
Over by the...
The lake.
Or...
Over...
Over around here.
Oh, okay.
We're going to Muntan.
To do the little...
Oh, wait!
I think I found it!
Who
needs flashing in from ocular migraines when you can have
ads?
Wait, this is so handy.
I think I'm gonna buy the soundtrack right after this.
I'm not gonna lie.
Well, there's only a few, like, soundtracks I've bought off
of Steam.
I think Metal Gear did not have one, if I remember
correctly.
No, but the... What's it called?
Collection did.
The Master Collection did.
So I have that.
I bought the Outer Wilds one, and I think I'll get this one.
It's, like, so good.
Delta dropped the vinyl.
Yeah, I have that.
So from here...
We go this way.
The cooking pot.
What was it?
ate a girl.
Oh, there we go.
I guess we could have... Well, I can't buy a cooking pot
anyway.
We gotta go this way.
Oh, I forgot I had a delivery.
Oh, my gosh.
I forgot I had one.
I have to be careful.
I can't just drive willy-nilly.
I don't care about my own life in the game.
Pizza!
Oh, my gosh.
Owl's Pizza Palace.
You have a record player yet?
I don't think so.
This must be.
Snow!
Yes, snowy peaks right at the top.
whoops who is heavy i have low energy get me in oh shoot oh
my god wait wait
Please!
Oh!
That was close.
I
don't have enough money still though.
One
second.
Now I can finally take my medicine.
Uh, the radio tower.
We have to keep going.
Oh, that's so rude that there's these places but you can't
go inside them.
Where is my welcoming hospitality.
Where is my southern hospitality?
Huh?
Where are they?
Not opening up their doors to those in need.
I'm just a starving little kitten.
With starving kitten in search of Discord mod.
Ghost don't need to eat.
They don't need to know that.
Oh no, it's this situation again.
Wait, what's going on there?
Does it say beware of bears?
Wait, what does it say?
Nothing.
Oh, you think I'll make it?
Oh,
look in first-person view.
You're so smart.
We're fine.
I really don't want to go up there in the dark, but I think
we must.
I have higher fueled or higher, what's it called?
Warmth.
Okay.
Just in case rip.
No!
Believe, believe!
Where is it though?
Oh my gosh, there's another staircase.
Please, please, please, please, please, please, please.
Please, please, please, please.
I will seek shelter.
I'm seeking shelter right now.
I'm seeking it up this staircase.
I'm seeking it up the staircase.
We're so close!
Oh my gosh, it's right there.
Let me in, let me in.
Yes!
Oh!
Yeah!
Baby!
Sorry.
Head to fishing town and open the security gate.
I gotta give me a cooking pot.
Wait, I don't think I have any more.
Wait.
Make sure your energy isn't too low before venturing into
the cold.
Holding a lighter will slow down freezing but...
Oh my gosh, sorry my contacts.
Won't prevent it entirely.
Campfires provide a great deployable source of warmth.
A brewed cup of tea provides temporary immunity to freezing.
That's why we had the tea!
I see, I see.
My...
It could be better.
Blizzard out my window.
Blizzard in the game.
No escape for me.
No!
Wait.
Vider?
Okay, good.
Alright, we're running.
I wonder if there's anything I can lie.
You know?
Oh my gosh.
I don't want to die.
Is this like something I can lie?
I can't set arson to the tree?
Okay.
Seek shelter.
Oh, God, already!
Get down there!
Oh, it felt so...
It felt like it took so long.
Going up, then it did going down.
Yippee!
We're too good, guys.
We're too good.
Oh.
Let's see if there's, like, a...
job up here before I go anywhere else.
This is, I need more money.
Fishing town.
Just got here, but I hope you had a good holiday.
You too, Gundam Wing.
Thank you.
Mountain town.
I guess we go back to Mountain town?
Let's try local.
Lopton.
Wait, Muntin to Wintin.
We could do that one.
We have to go back to Monday anyway.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Let's do this one.
And then we could get the cooking pot, I think.
Easy, ma!
Hope you're good.
Kimmish.
You too!
Weezy, thank you.
You too, you too, you too.
Let her cook.
We're cooking, we're cooking.
We are cooking.
I don't think the intercity ones are worth it right now.
Or they might be, but...
If we're just staying in this area anyway...
Might be better.
And across the bridge!
That was a turn.
I need to stop looking at chat.
Stop reading chat and pay attention to the road.
Chowderful, welcome to Mambuship Day.
Ooh, this way.
Okay.
Do not look.
I'm looking.
I'm looking at all your pretty faces.
How could I not look?
I've missed you guys.
Wait.
When I don't stream for so long.
Wait, where was the bridge?
Did I miss it?
Oh, okay.
Just kidding.
Wee-roop.
Guys, I'll let you know in advance.
I don't really have so much plans.
for New Year's.
I hope that's okay.
I've been so busy with planning everything else.
I suddenly was like, wait a second.
Oh!
Where am I going?
Mountain.
It's kind of going to be a little chill.
I hope that's okay.
I'm sure a bunch of other people are doing things.
And I will, I actually will have two, well, I won't be
streaming on the second one, but um i'll have i'll be
appearing in two streams chill is good too i think after
honestly whatever the heck this year was chill sounds kind
of nice what am i picking up from oh from the very top tippy
top
so yeah
chill new years with you couldn't ask for more yippee i will
be counting down for east coast obviously so um since i am
east coast oh gosh it will be it will be chill i can't
believe though that next week It'll be 2026 But not gonna
lie I don't know, my brain has already started thinking in
2026 I think because I've been planning so much Hey mate I
seem to have dropped the feminist literature I was just
reading Any chance you've seen it around What is that?
What does that have to do with the packages?
Oh wait No, close it There we go, get it I wonder what he
was reading.
Wait, before we do that, I'm going to get some more.
We need some more of this.
Oh gosh, wait, I'm low energy.
Oh my gosh, please, please, please, please, please, please,
please, please.
Bye.
Take it.
Please, take it.
Wait, oh, shoot.
Energy drink.
Drink it.
Aha!
Wait, did I get it?
No!
I'm back here.
This part's spooky, I don't like it.
The beaches?
I'm back!
Did I get to drink it?
I guess I did.
All right, that should be good then.
Is there an area like that under the main cabin?
Now why?
Why would I have that?
That would be ridiculous.
Pretty sure you can recycle the empty cans for cash.
No kidding!
For fun?
We have the room where the girls whisper into your ear.
mid, ghost mid, girl ASMR.
Where am I going to?
Oh, I'm delivering it up here!
I thought I was delivering it to Winton!
Wait, now I'm confused.
It totally said Winton, did it not?
Huh.
That's weird.
Hmm.
Why did it change?
I'm hungry.
Can we stop for Nuggies?
No stop in this car!
This is express delivery.
This ain't your...
This ain't your Blamazons.
This is Easy Co.
I have to use the bathroom.
There's a cup bath.
I have five empty cans.
It's like in the middle.
Right here.
Here?
No.
Not the pink house.
Abort.
Nice.
Nothing was even spilled even a little bit.
Seb.
Seb would have stopped for Nuggies.
Don't bring up that man's name in my presence.
Merry Christmas!
Wicked Wint!
Try it!
Thank you!
Merry Christmas!
Alright, let's see.
I turn around.
We'll just go the other way.
Actually, do you think I could go up?
I think I can go this way?
We have all-wheel drive.
Just kidding.
Oh, just kidding.
We're fine.
Let's go back this way.
Now, I thought all-wheel drive was supposed to handle any
tough terrain.
It's in the name.
All-wheel.
Keep going.
I think four-wheel drive is better.
Four wheel, five wheel.
Wait, where am I?
Where am I supposed to get this thing?
Uh...
The depot in snowy peaks.
Maybe further.
I think I just did this earlier.
Yes, I did.
Collision?
Oops.
No, please!
Why are you like this to me?
Why not eight wheel?
Ten wheel drive.
Oh, please, I'm worried about Ellie.
Could you try to go check on them?
When I try to leave this spot, I free SD49 errors up.
I'll just be here.
Third wheel drive is most socially awkward.
Is that like a third?
Oh my gosh, a third wheel.
You're hitting Mike Tyson's ass!
Thank you!
I've been really enjoying Night of the Chubakabra!
Thank you so much.
No, everyone, welcome back.
Thank you.
Let's go check up on Ellie.
We can make it, right?
Huh?
Have you spoken to Fortino, that sad guy recently?
Every time I see them, they run away and hide.
Yeah, okay, great, good.
I think Ellie's fine.
all right let's get our coffee maker do I have to buy the
coffee too I'll just be here cooking oh I got an email about
cooking wait oh shoot I'm back in okay there we go camera
cooking how to cook build a campfire with two pieces of
firewood drop a piece of firewood on the ground place
another on top start the fire with a lighter place the
cooking pot on top and add an ingredient ingredients vary in
yield and cook time wood stoves can also be cooked on okay
so I do need the coffee powder and I'm broke I can't I can't
even afford it duct tape I can't afford I can't afford
anything.
I'm broke,
Mito finally gonna learn how to cook.
I've been watching Breaking... I've been watching Breaking
Bad!
Oh, I own this store now.
I mean, I could buy an energy drink.
What do I have in here?
Nothing much.
We could do one other job.
Let's pick another job.
Job.
And local.
Give me the big bucks.
Winton to Muntin.
Sounds like a job for me.
Pick up at the Winton.
See?
Yeah, okay.
Delivery in the Muntin.
Alright.
That's a big enough bucks for me.
Start the job.
Easy flowers.
Okay.
Luckily I have enough money for a drink if I need it.
Wait, shortcut.
Actually, I'm lost.
Off-roading?
Yeah, baby.
I think it's over here.
Yes.
Yes, baby.
Solid boot cat tune.
Puts and cats and boots and cats and boots and cats and
boots and cats.
I'm gonna need to get more gas soon, too.
Oh, wait.
Okay, we go to Winton.
Pick up in Winton, everybody.
Remember that.
I might actually have to get gas with the amount that I
have.
Wait, do you think I can use...
Oh, wait.
Okay, well, we don't have to buy the fire.
Because there's a storm.
I just dove in this cabin up here.
I really get to watch live due to time zones.
So it's nice to be able to catch a stream.
Happy holidays in the UK!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you!
Happy holidays!
Can I not cook?
Please let me cook.
Please!
Let her cook.
The cat knows I'm about to do Breaking Bad in their house.
Oh, wait, the dog.
My bad.
This is WK.
Oh, no.
Sorry.
MK.
Oh, my God.
M.M.
Mautomorable.
Flip it around.
Wicked witch.
Wee!
I've literally flipped it around in my brain.
do you think actual drug dealers talk about breaking bad i
bet probably no i feel like if i were a drug dealer i'd be
like yo it's from the flowers right gotta
catch up on some vibes but i'm excited to see the off collab
and see all my girlies no me me me so cute yeah another fun
year i mean I think he's a boy.
Me, me, me, me.
Good greetings.
I met new friends yesterday at the coffee shop.
There's so accepting of me.
Me, me, you gotta cook.
I'm cooking, I'm cooking.
As a drug seller, it rarely comes up.
No, but back in the heyday, it had to be.
My dad knew a former meth addict and asked him about
Breaking Bad and the guy said the show was too glamorous.
Glamorous?
glamorous
maybe from all the money you make I mean it's Hollywood they
gotta you know
meth cooking is hard it's rough yeah but that's why it was
so good for him for Walter White because he is the chemistry
tensile so of course Jesse's teeth were too oh my god you
bringing that up is so funny because literally as i was
watching an episode today i was like man jesse has really
nice teeth like it's so it's kind of taking me out his teeth
were way too nice i totally thought that we need to cook and
spread christmas joy
when i was on the tron ride there was one thing that was so
funny about it is so basically the tron ride is you're about
to do the race and the evil guy is just like i have come and
i have taken over the system except the way he says it is so
like i have to say it like that he comes in and he's just
like spread my code and you're like on the ride and he's
like keep spreading and you're like oh why
Spread my code.
At the end.
At the end when you beat him, he's just like, no.
Which is pretty funny, but...
I was like, why is he saying it like that?
Spread my code.
He's gonna try on all over.
Spread that code everywhere.
I was just like...
You should...
It's at the very beginning of the ride if you ever look up
like a...
Like a... what's it called?
Like a...
Ride...
View...
Like first person view or something.
It's so funny.
I've taken over the grid.
You must spread my code.
No!
Don't tell me that!
Don't tell me to do that!
Like why is he so...
Hello, Mito.
Good evening, good evening!
Because you wouldn't complete the ritual.
No, the gods!
So many new friends!
I'll take that.
Thank you very much.
Place.
Close.
Oh!
Whoa!
My car was haunted for a second.
I think I can get gas from this.
Let's do that.
Oh.
Let me in.
spooky whatever they're paying you i'll pay you slightly
less to go away that'll be 40 you don't have enough funds
okay take my money and take my money
okay we're this is true gosh i know this life way too much
where you're just like okay we're right under half we're
doing good guys we're doing good this is this is too real
maybe I wonder oh wait we were gonna do this job and then we
were gonna get coffee I remember
I think I'll be able to buy two things of coffee so that'll
be good we can have four cups
Monty.
Coffee pot.
We already bought the coffee pot, luckily.
So that big cost is out of the way.
We just gotta buy the coffee itself.
Alright.
Okay, we just keep following the road.
I'm gonna have coffee all in my shorts.
You know?
I'll be pouring him in my pockets and then just like sucking
my pockets to get any ounce of coffee they'll be sopping wet
you know I just like twist it into my mouth you know what I
mean
I'm sucking my pockets like the fabric of my pockets but why
because I'm storing the coffee in my How else would you do
it?
Oops.
Off-roading?
We're spreading code now.
I love a good code spread.
I don't want to say it.
I don't want to...
She's gonna have wet pockets.
Wait,
my gas is already so low.
What's happening?
I guess this is a pretty long drive.
a small table onto the passenger seat and get a cigarette
light adapter.
You have boiling water.
So true!
Never change.
What did I say?
Oh my gosh.
The plants.
Okay, we're fine.
We're too good at this job.
We're gonna have to fill up at Easton.
Eaton.
Or Eaton good.
Oh, whoops.
Let's get a little closer.
Place.
Yippee!
Close.
Get in.
Oh, my energy.
Wait.
Easy Mart.
We'll have it.
What am I doing?
Oh my gosh.
Get in.
Enter.
Coffee powder.
Oh, what did you say?
6.98.
Okay, thank you.
Cheers.
All right, put it away.
Coffee powder, more.
Bye.
I like to start my day with a simple 17-mile kilometer jog
filed by three hours of meditation.
You should try some time.
Cheers.
Okay, I'm going to get one can of energy drink because we're
so low.
Cheers.
All right, now we can drink this.
Did I say 17 mile kilometers?
Sorry.
You know, we're bridging the gaps, everybody.
The cultural gaps.
For those who don't understand miles and for those who don't
understand kilometers.
I am worldwide!
I wonder what the duct tape in the birdseed is for.
I'm just making it easy for everybody.
I come from Chupacabra.
Welcome!
It's the night of the Chupacabra!
It's funny, uh, the, um, the person who did the lyrics for
Night of the Chupacabra, she, I got to see her at, uh, the
Mid Cafe.
And I was like, thank you for the lyrics.
And the bing bing bong, I think, was directly from, like,
bing bing bing bing bing bing bing bing.
So, that's like an actual Minto reference.
Shortcut.
Yeah.
Bing bong is canon.
I'm going to go do some more jobs in, like, the mountain
area.
But first, I'm going to...
That's cool.
Yeah, I thought so.
I was like, oh, this is such a nice touch.
I'm, I'm in, I'm a canon Toho.
Toho lore or something.
Oh, that's, there goes my car.
It's fine, it'll come back down.
There you go then.
There we go.
Your pocket coffee is going to turn to iced coffee in this
weather.
Yummy.
Coffee powder.
Cook.
Minky Toho stream win!
What game should I play?
Oh, I think it's ready.
I think I should just make all of it.
Cherno one.
Which one?
Start at the first one.
Like PC 98?
First one?
EOSD.
That does have my wife in it.
My mistress.
Remilia Scarlet.
Minto Thon is beating every Toho game in order on night.
That's the entire...
My whole week... I think it would take longer than I'm not
gonna lie.
I would have to truly lock in.
I do think though some things will be like watchalongs of at
least like, what's the word?
Royalty, no, public domain movies and things like that.
So that I can just kind of like rest and watch a movie.
I don't know, it'll be like for me a 2 a.m.
movie or something.
So that way you guys don't have to get the movies or
anything like that either.
You can just watch some old classics.
Oh, let's get a job.
Local.
Give me the big bucks.
Big bucks.
140 kilograms, but it's just only...
Wait, it's so much.
That's like the opposite of what we need to do.
West and Eastern.
Okay, we'll do that one.
Pick up from Easy Depot.
Ace Combat.
I think, though, for Ace Combat games, I want to like make
them, I want to start it with like a...
As like an individual stream.
Not in the Dono.
Not, oh my gosh.
I can't call it a Dono-Tan.
What do I call it?
Minto-Tan.
I guess.
It's a YouTube channel called Broken Trout that specializes
in public domain noir.
Pope Sci-Fi films.
Oh!
Thank you, Doc.
Wait, Doc Talk, can you comment that so I can look it up
later?
Minto-Tan.
Non-stop Minto.
Oh!
Minky's on.
I want to try and focus on like non...
What's the word?
Games that are not like super story heavy, you know, since
I'll be streaming for so long.
I don't want people to come in and be like, I'm lost, you
know what I mean?
I've played some mainline Toho games and they are truly
hard.
Oh yeah!
I've beaten the... I've beaten... Oh gosh, I can't even
remember anymore.
EOSD I beat back in the day.
Um,
what else?
Mountain of Faith, I think.
I don't remember.
Western.
Easy people.
Do you like to scare?
And when you scare, do you become a...
nightmare i'm golden minke i like to scare and when i scare
i become a nightmare wait easy depot right yes you're in the
office oh
probably gonna die and you will die because you won't
survive what am i here for oh the pickup hello I stood with
Ellie all night last night, but now I can't as SD49 air seem
to move.
Tell Ellie, welcome valued customer DD78.
Hear me out, Kerbal, stay- Oh, guys.
You want me to use my brain for real?
I'll become an engineer.
I guess Minky-Ton is a perfect excuse to return to YouTube
playable.
So good, so true.
I have a secret.
I've been playing them off stream.
The YouTube playables.
I've been playing them.
Without us?
I'm sorry!
Wait, we just watched this guy get reset in front of us.
How might we assist you today?
The payload.
He just got reset in front of us.
She plays games not for content.
Okay, but most games I play for content.
But there are sometimes games, like YouTube playables, that
probably don't.
I'm turning it down just a tad.
You don't need to see every YouTube playable, do you?
Wait, why am I delivering this to you?
Okay, right by the fuel.
Oh, I think it's pizza.
Yappa games.
Yappa dappa do!
Oh, this way.
Shortcut.
Pizza!
Oh, we almost lost pizza.
Oh, ouch.
Wait, my car!
Oh, shoot.
Wait.
Come back.
I forgot to park.
Right here?
Where are you?
Oh, here.
Have an easy day!
Awesome.
Oh, we need gas.
Bad, bad, okay.
No, he's gonna take all our money!
Can't believe my Oshi's into Neto game.
I know I'm trash!
Min-totan, beating every YouTube playable on Nightmare.
Exactly who I wanted to see.
To prove that there is no such thing as a benevolent god.
Oh my god.
I hear the long dark 2 is coming out next year and it's
multiplayer.
So it might be a fun thing to try.
Long dark.
Dude.
Give me $60.
I don't have that!
26.43.
Now go away.
I'm taking my money.
What are we at?
Okay, we're at halfway.
Let's go to Fishtown.
There should be gas and jobs there, right?
Surely.
No money.
Tunnel to fish.
Oh!
Radio tower, just kidding.
I was about to be like, what a second?
I saw wood there.
I'm gonna burn that wood.
We already went there.
I lived and I died there.
Back it up.
The eyeball yearn for slump!
I'm really glad I'm...
Can I just say for a second that I'm really like...
um you know i know that i was pretty like well about about
wisp and i boo and all the other everything so i'm really
i'm really glad that you guys accepted it so quickly and
everything and that you guys were so patient with me and
everything so so thank you for like you know just kind of
being like yeah like i said if you still want to use wisp of
course you're totally valid in doing so but as the fan name
but yeah thank you everybody thank you
boom i think it's cute too in the game house wait what if i
drop downstairs i hear him playing the this what if i drop
down here oh Oh wait, this actually does go down though.
Oh shoot, I'm gonna die.
Open the gate.
Security gate complete.
You're the eye best.
I liked being a wisp, but if it causes a lisp, I will
desist.
It's nothing to cry, boo-boo about.
I think it also allows for funny wordplay too.
know fishing town open security hit i did it what does i
blue mean it's a play on the word eyeball which is means
like partner you know like like hey you're my you're my
partner eyeball in japanese but then boo because i'm a ghost
boo i keep reading that as get a house Wait, aren't you
gonna open?
Wait.
We're spooky?
Yeah, spooky.
Maybe it went down.
Maybe it's timed.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
Blast it!
Oh, it does.
It is timed, okay.
Hello!
It's good to see you here.
I need you to get the supplies from the dam, but it's
guarded by more gates.
Not as big as this one though.
Seems like with enough force, you could smash through them!
Read at the easy auto.
Here we'll set you up.
Bumper bar.
Can we be your eternal partners, Minto?
Well, I'm eternal.
17.
I mean, sorry.
I did.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, my gosh.
I'm so tired.
No, the...
So, I mean, as long as I don't go, as long as I don't pass
on, then, you know.
As long as we're yours, partner.
No, I'm legal.
Lying about her age?
No!
I'm not!
It's because You know, so many say you say they're forever
17.
But I'm 19.
So it's like it just comes out my mouth is forever 17.
Oh my gosh, Nimmy Nightmare is playing Outer Wild.
I wonder if she's recording more.
Anyway, sorry.
They'll still make you pay.
It's not their fault.
You'll probably need to take some more delivery jobs.
In the meantime, I'll figure out a way to get this gate open
permanently.
You're stuck on this side for now.
There used to be some great spots for ice fishing.
I think Fortino has a fishing rod on sale at the depot.
No wonder if the fish are still biting.
Good luck out there.
Nimmy exposed.
She posted about it.
That she was...
Did we get a new song then?
I've been listening to this song for a while, so I'm like,
ready for a new soundtrack, you know?
Wait, so what's the map here?
what is this oh bumper bar where are we
I don't know you can change stations to hear other music
tracks how do I change stations alright to smolton to
dampton to clifton let's take on a job
because I have no money and I need $100?
Uh-oh.
Guys, we might have to take on, like, a ton of jobs.
These are...
These are small.
Uh-oh.
No money.
Let's do this one, because it's...
Smallton?
Easy pizza.
Where are...
Smolton.
Easy pizza.
Okay, so to...
To Smolton, Dampton?
Okay.
Yeah, I'm sorry.
Oh, I'm sorry.
I have to say the forbidden J word.
Yab.
What's my favorite episode of Breaking Bad so far?
Oh.
I don't know.
Um...
Leaving Clifton.
I don't know.
How far are you?
I'm season two, episode three, I think?
I'm gonna watch more after stream maybe if I'm not too
tired.
But I'm not very far in.
Smolton Walter white oh Skyler white yo wife of Walter white
yo did I just go over a bridge where am I what's this way
I'm I boo yo fan of mint phantom yo
Fuel, okay.
Well, we are not...
Okay, we're here.
Okay, ah, I was down here.
Okay, okay, okay.
I thought I was over here.
Shortcut?
Yo.
There's, like, houses on the water.
Interesting.
Okay.
What do they belong to?
Is that pizza?
Oh, I need to ram into that, don't I?
No stinking way.
They're ice fishing huts.
Oh, that's so cute!
Hey, when you see old Tooe again, give him a dead-eyed stare
for me.
Would you?
I'll take that.
Thank you very much.
You think I can ram that yet?
Probably not.
Let's try it.
Damnton.
All right, so we are headed to...
No way.
We have to go around the entire map.
We have to go around the entire map, even though it's just
right there.
Oh, evil!
It's Darnton.
The Great Trek.
This person will get their beer when it's beer clock.
Which is on my terms.
Darn it.
I'm sad that the days are getting longer now.
I want to live in a place that looks like this all the time.
Like this?
I don't think I can live without the sun.
Well, you know, I can't live at all, but I don't like to be
without the sun.
You know?
Wait, raise your hand if this is like your peak weather all
the time.
If you would be so happy with this.
It's my dream too.
Really?
I missed this up.
No, we're not going to Clifton.
That's Clifton We're going to Dampton I'm cold at 70 Whoa
there's so You guys are raising your hands For real Not all
the time I think this would get like really All the time
This would get too much No I mean there is something super
cozy about this kind of weather too though I won't lie
It would be living in Florida You think so Oh, this isn't so
bad of a...
Oh, whoops.
This way.
That was actually pretty fast, you guys.
Good job.
That wasn't so bad at all.
Yahoo!
I prefer the cold for sure.
Really?
Smallton to Clifton.
I want shouldn't be so bad.
Wait, is it pizza again?
We're in Dampton right now.
Maybe we go to, wait, Smolton is all the way to the other
side again.
If I could turn down my draw distance IRL, I would silent
hill peak weather.
No way.
I think we gotta focus on the big money.
Oh my god, going all the way back to Easy Pizza.
Okay.
I was just out in the cold while I was gone.
wasn't bad at all.
Let's see if we can break down the thing over here.
Maybe on one side.
Here I go!
Sad.
Wait, what is this?
I cannot go in.
I cannot get up.
Oh my god.
Can I go in over here?
Is this a door?
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
I wish
I had more snow.
Snow, snow.
We need more snow.
Now we're back to Boots and Cats.
We've been out to Boots and Cats.
Wait.
I'm going to Smalton, not Clifton.
Or, wait.
Oh, just kidding.
Yes.
Stay frosty.
Oh yeah baby I don't know I like I think I appreciate Okay
It's gonna sound so I romanticize like the weather Like a
little bit you know Where it's like If it's this kind of
weather I'm gonna want to be With like a coffee All bundled
up in a blanket Or like a tea With tea or something I think
that's the Only wait, that's the, I feel like that's the
best way to get through the weather and all.
Know exactly what you mean.
Yeah, like, I want to be at, like, a bookstore cafe or
something.
And, like, just kind of, that's how I will weather the
storm.
Kind of way.
Cozy streamer.
Ah!
Smolting.
Alright, let's get that.
Wait, is it this way?
I think so.
I think up there was the gas station.
Which we're gonna need gas soon-ish.
Oh my gosh, they're gonna eat all of our money before we
can...
Best way for this weather is with a Minto stream.
So true.
Whoops, my bad.
Screamer.
Is Mint Phantom a screamer?
Hey!
How come Iziko gave you a right-hand drive truck?
Better yet, how come they let you drive at all?
You drive like a goose-gain sentience and lost its morals.
What?
Why are you guys... What's wrong?
Wait, what?
Honk!
Holy cow!
So much pizza!
I think you guys were the super chats.
For some reason, I used to be able to get out of...
Hold on.
I'm going to try this.
Oh, there we go.
Whether I want to be blanketed up with hot cocoa, book two,
and not dropping off this cliff.
Big same-sies.
Looks like I'm getting more than 50 degree temperature drop
in the next couple...
Oh!
That's so much!
All the pizza.
Where am I going?
Clift.
They won't mind.
Look at that.
Only lost one.
Easy.
I'm too good.
The best pizza in all of London.
Owl's pizza palace.
You guys think the headlights are doing anything?
You're delivering to Brent Halligan.
I need to play more silly point-and-click-im.
I was thinking about playing Freddy Fish today.
I think I talked about it on stream.
I was like, oh my gosh, I want to play Freddy Fish.
Relive my childhood.
And I was going to play it today.
And then, oh, shoot.
I was going to include it on my 50 yintins this year.
But I was reading the reviews.
and some of the reviews they weren't bad in that like the
like it was breaking like in breaking bugs or anything like
that but there was people being like you know i can't really
recommend this game to adults or like they were like it's
great for maybe like nostalgia but if you didn't play this
game it's kind of bad and i was like oh no like it's my own
selfish request to play it but if it's bad for anybody else
then like i don't want you know if someone's just like i
don't i didn't play this so it's stupid and bad your stream
of it
you think it'd still be fun though i think so wait wait
other way Sounds peak.
You think they were being too serious?
Uh-oh.
Oh.
Let's go.
For sure.
Have an easy day.
All right, we're not even halfway through.
Oh, and I...
Oh my gosh, the fishing rod is $124!
Intercity deliveries are a stronger source of income.
That's what we need right now.
And you need money for gas.
I know they're going to take like $60 for gas.
Gates and trees.
Wait a second.
Let's do Clifton to Dampton.
Because we're right here.
Pick up from Easy Auto.
Okay.
Is this easy auto?
This is the bar.
There's one Freddy Fish game with an easter egg where Freddy
Fish fantasizes about murdering his friend.
Why is the pizza?
It fell over.
No way.
This is easy, Mark.
Where is it?
Easy auto.
I'm off-roading.
Oh!
It's gonna have the porch light on.
Oh, that's right.
Cosmology of Kyoto.
Journeyman Project Turbo, Space Quest.
Conquest of the Longbow.
I've never heard of literally a single one of these.
Oh, I think... Okay, I know where we are.
We got our Yui.
There we go.
This way.
Oh gosh, my energy.
Oh my god, my energy.
Oh?
Seb spoke so much more than you do I?
You're not really a talker.
Also, remind me, I have to remember to tell you something.
I've forgotten already.
Cosmology of Kyoto is pretty creative.
Why is this like so all over the place?
Okay.
Where are we taking this bad boy to?
Damten.
If we're Gour.
I want to meet this Seb guy.
She seems really well liked.
And we are not so well liked, perhaps.
Well, we're the new guy.
They don't have a chance to know us yet.
You know?
We just have to really show them what we're made of.
It is so hard to see!
I hope I'm going the right way.
Where's the signs at?
Wait, am I going in a circle?
To Smalton, to Dampton.
Yeah, wait, I just went in a big circle.
Uh-oh.
Oh.
Okay.
To Smalton, to Dampton.
I'm wasting gas, you guys.
This is so bad.
We're here?
Here?
I think?
Keep your eyes peeled for any signs?
Wait, why is it just go in a circle?
Wait?
Oh, did I go this way?
Wait.
Wait a second.
Peeling my eyes?
Wait, where am I?
I hate this map.
So stinking much.
What?
I'm gonna run out of gas.
No!
It's a circle!
Wait.
Oh no.
Oh no no.
No no no.
You're at the bottom left of the maps to this one.
Easy auto.
Okay, so I'm just here.
Oh, it's pointing this way, right?
Wait, is it?
I thought...
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, sorry.
I thought because it was pointing...
It was on to the left side.
I thought...
Wait, to Dampton.
We're fine.
Oh my god.
We're going to Dampton, right?
Minto DoorDash.
I'm at least not stealing your food.
I'm gonna lose all my...
Oh, this sucks.
Wait, this is so annoying.
I wish they would have told me that I would be making
pennies in here.
Because...
I'm gonna have to get gas, and then we're gonna lose all my
money.
No, this sucks so much.
To Dampton.
It's like life.
Noor!
Can we go back to another zone?
They said that we can't.
Alright, we're in Dampton now.
Allegedly.
Whenever we see a way to go to the left.
The first road.
To our left.
Take that.
So.
Are you implying that DoorDash steals food?
Every time I hear about the...
About DoorDash, it's always that somebody got their food
stolen by the driver.
I don't use DoorDash or anything like that, so.
I don't know.
But that's all I've ever heard.
heard is it true is it reliable service i guess i mean
obviously depends on the driver that's delivering it but
when the order comes short a few nuggets the minto
guarantees that they fell off the job what yam flu welcome
to membership thank you
maybe we can get one from dampton to smallton like this one
but more money cliffton to smallton wait smallton to no well
do Clifton to Smolton, because we gotta go over to Clifton
again.
That depends, I suppose, seems to cost more than worth.
What, DoorDash?
I think so, too.
Doki has a lot of Uber Eats stores, but mostly not stolen
food.
Nah, well, thank you so much!
Thank you!
Okay, we'll do this one, because we have to go this way
anyway.
Or...
No.
I think we go get gas.
We're gonna have 50 cents to our name, pretty much.
Let's go get gas.
Is it this way?
Shortcut!
Oops.
50 cents in a dream.
I'm in a place where the only way to get pizza delivered is
through a breeze.
Oh, I just go pick it up.
because also you get like the pickup deals too you know
where it's like oh if you come in to get the pizza here
we'll give you a little bit off and I'm like hi dog I'll
take that low fuel uh oh guys we might be cooked what
happens if we're low fuel do they take all of our money and
fill it up I imagine that's That's probably how it works,
but we'll see.
I'm not going to Clifton, I'm going to Smelton!
See?
We're okay, we're okay.
There could be some more signage though, Alguerrug.
I think we're almost there.
Wait, are we gonna make it?
Wait.
Oh, this is pizza.
Oh no, I went to pizza!
it's back here oh my gosh wait are we gonna make it you guys
will my mistake cost us will my mistake cost us oh
we're so close watch we die right in front of the gas
station that'd be crazy
holy cow we made it oh
come surely this will have no environmental impact.
I'd go over there and untie your shoes.
But you're not worth the effort.
That's...
Oh, only 39!
Oh, let's go!
Does that fill me up?
Let's go!
We didn't lose all of our money!
Wait, why was it sometimes $60?
Am I getting scammed?
Uh...
I think I was getting scammed.
Let's do Clifton to Dampton.
Pick up from bar.
Alright, I know where that is.
I know where that is.
Shortcut.
Loyalty bonus?
Maybe.
Good question.
Game is trying to scam me for real.
At least it doesn't have, like, surge pricing when I
desperately need fuel.
DoorDash dropped off four pizzas that I didn't order on my
driveway.
weeks ago.
I found out, called them, and they told me to keep them.
I got four pizzas, so worth of zero dollars.
Nice.
I wish that would happen to me.
Alright, Clifton, Clifton, Clifton.
There we are.
That's a hell yeah, brother.
Hell yeah, brother!
Free pizza.
What?
But, okay.
At the same time, though, I'm very picky about my pizza.
If it's not the kind of pizza that I want, I'll be like,
Peebza money.
Oh, Mr. Yaya!
Thank you.
Is this the bar?
Wait, where's the bar?
Are you the bar?
Pawn shop.
The prawn shop.
It's a weird story.
My four pizzas never...
Drama.
DRAMA OY Maybe I'm too hard on 6-0 Maybe life is all about
supporting the people you love Can't expect anything in
return One of the pizzas was ham, pineapple, and jalapeno
Ah, see, I wouldn't be able to eat that Yummy, but would you
be able to handle it?
I don't think so
What's a minto pizza?
Like Mostly veggie.
Us, uns, uns, uns, uns, uns.
Like, I'm a veggie pizza believer.
Wait, so if I go out this way, keep to the right.
Is this a road?
Oh, it is.
I didn't think this was a road.
Wait, maybe this is not a road.
Oh.
Oops.
Ah,
we're lost.
Wait, where am I?
Wait, I'm lost.
Leaving.
Oh, perfect.
We made it up.
What road did I take then?
We have no recovery.
We still have one left, so we're okay, I think.
thinking now i want pizza yeah i like veggie pizza like um
give me like a spinch give me tomato give me liberty give me
death see everything's fine guys easy peasy have an easy day
all right let's see we're in dampton right now
Damton the Smallton Oh that's a lot of money though My
favorite pizza is a brick I love brick oven pizza It's so
good Her
name is Spinch Phantom I love Spinch It's so good Oh my gosh
I love making Okay when I was a poor college student I would
make rice and then spinach.
I would cook spinach in sesame oil and have that over rice
and that would be my meal.
So yummy.
Yummy, yummy, yummy.
But like cooking the spinach in the sesame oil.
Just a tiny bit.
It would last me a long time.
I do enjoy a healthy amount of veggies on pizza.
New Year's Wish.
Maybe a playthrough of the PS2 Madagascar King.
Hopefully finish Battle Block with Barry.
Thank you!
It's your doku whisper calling me.
We are OC, thank you!
No garlic?
Oh, garlic is a given, because I'm a garlic girl.
No, I, um...
I'm finishing Battle Block with Barry next week.
Yes, I am!
Clifton the Smallton, or Damton the Smallton.
This one, we are carrying it for a less amount of time.
Actually, I want to skip Clifton all together so let's do
the Damton to Smolton even though it's about the same amount
of money easy cafe okay which is where upper upper Dampton
garlic and onions yeah hi boss you're going you blessed a
cookie recipe I made for the holiday get together had a lot
of people this year asking for the mint cookies that don't
have mint.
They don't do VTubers.
Back here!
Oh my gosh, I feel like it's been a while.
I'm glad people like their recipe.
Why didn't you ask me to bless them this year, huh?
Where am I going?
Where am I picking up from?
Easy, cafe.
Where am I?
I've been lurking.
I see.
Well, thanks for saying hi.
Thank you.
You know, I miss you guys when you don't comment.
Not to say that you can't lurk or anything, obviously.
But I do wonder about you guys, you know.
I'm like, hmm, I wonder where so-and-so is.
You might think, like, ah, she has such a big chat, she
doesn't notice.
But I do.
I probably see a lot more than you guys realize.
Dusty dog, thank you so much for the 10 gifted!
Jars of Christopher Ranch chopped garlic is yummy.
Christopher Ranch.
Are you sure that, wait, is that ranch or is it garlic?
She's stalking us.
Is that a threat?
Maybe.
Like I see when you, when, I see your posts.
I see when you Ashi-hen!
Fancy seeing you here.
Every once in a while I wonder whether I should be flirting
with everyone I meet.
Wait a second, they're not behind the counter anymore.
But then I remember everyone I meet is incredibly
attractive.
Oh, oh my god!
Thank you.
All right.
Is it Oshi Henning?
If it's Densitou EXE?
No!
Of course you can Oshi...
Oshi Densitou.
Yubi!
Thank you for the membership!
Welcome, welcome!
Let's see, we're going to...
Right by pizza.
Alright, let's go to pizza.
Don't mind that.
Crackers, cheese, and various deli meats is called girl
dinner.
but I thought it was called charcuterie no I don't think
that's girl dinner at all because that sounds like an actual
like that's like something you actually eat that's like
that's a meal you know what I mean a girl dinner would be
like cheese and ham and like like a cold pizza um uh like
fruit snacks yeah girl dinner's more fair yeah yeah I just
forgot to do my monthly Do your dailies.
Remember, Ibu, she knows when you're sleeping.
Yeah.
I know.
I feel called out.
Wait, is it this way?
I think so?
Yes.
To Clifton, Smolton.
I feel very called out by your desperation.
Girl dinner.
Then you understand, you know, girl dinner.
what is the opposite what is like a boy dinner i imagine
like meats or something you know i don't know like bacon and
hams and sausages nuggets oh that's also part of girl dinner
though i believe pizza maybe it's maybe it's not so
different term girl dinner then You know, maybe we're all
not that different after all.
Boys and girls.
Maybe we're all just the same.
A little silly.
Eyes on the road.
I'm a responsible driver.
I looked away for two seconds.
Nice and easy.
Sorry if I miss your super chill messages.
But thank you guys.
Thank you so, so, so much.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
All right, we're headed to pizza, but not exactly pizza.
All right, hopefully we can get in a few more deliveries
to...
Hopefully it doesn't take very long.
Wait, oh, shoot.
I think boy dinner is one Rubik's Cube with ranch.
Oh, delicacy.
Yay!
About a year ago, I asked if it was going to use your
karaoke songs for a custom art.
Yes!
I was wondering if you could bless me again to make another
one.
Wait, wait, wait, of what?
Of what?
Oh my gosh, oh my gosh, oh my gosh.
Wait.
where is this
no watching chat while driving sorry
I think it's this way maybe
yes yes I didn't even know there was a road back here aha
and wait where to go oh Oh no.
Wait.
Place.
Oh gosh.
Okay.
Another custom vinyl.
Yeah, but what's on?
Of course you can.
Of course.
But I'm just curious.
My cheap college go-to is making kind of scrambled or sunny
side eggs with hot sauce.
But that's not so cheap anymore.
Yeah, the eggy.
The eggy.
How much money do I have?
We're in Smolton now, right?
Let's do Smolton the Dampton is so far!
I
think I gotta do Clifton the Dampton.
Gotta focus on the big money.
pawn shop.
Okay.
I'm at $73.
I'm sick of this area.
I'm not gonna lie.
Can I just drive over the rocks?
Hmm.
I have a line on the list, but I'm thinking the jazz karaoke
stream is a start.
Yeah, of course.
Ram the gate.
It doesn't work.
I need the gate thing.
That's why I'm Saving up $100 for...
Unfortunately, I cannot ram the gate yet.
Ugh, it's kind of torture this area.
Okay, so we're going to Clifton.
Well, if the one from Smolton wasn't such small money, then
I would have taken it.
But I think we just need to do two more big jobs and then
we'll be good to go to buy it.
Oh, this part is, this kind of drags the, it's like so mean
that they give you such small bucks in this area.
Yeah, I do need coffee.
Don't worry.
Once we get out, I'll drink some.
I'll drink some inside the pawn shop.
It is the pawn shop.
Right?
Clifton.
It says there's a tunnel back, but I don't know.
I don't know if it'll work.
Oh, here it is.
Go, go, go, go, enter, enter, enter.
There we go.
I've done my own research on these deliveries and I've
determined that they definitely contain something suspicious
like cardboard.
Where do me this, Minto?
Which part of a road do ghosts love to travel the most?
The sidewalk?
Dead?
Ends!
You guys are so silly.
I don't like, I don't know how to get out of Clifton.
You got, oh no, Dampton is like on the ice.
Can I pay, buy it and then...
Then give you the money, the rest of it later?
Just fast travel, if only, right?
I think it's this one.
Was this the road?
Here we go!
Shortcut.
Are you breaking the law for not strapping down my load?
No!
Wait, where am I?
Obviously, no.
Oh my god.
We're two.
We're too good.
I'm glad this game ended up not being super spooky, though.
It's kind of nice.
It's like, it's pretty good.
Alright.
I don't like that it shows me...
Oh.
It shows me the delivery thing, but like...
It's always on the left side, so it's kind of confusing.
Because it's like...
I wish it just showed me where to go.
You know what I mean?
Oh, see, it's getting big again.
Uh-oh.
Oh, oh.
Ah!
How do I do this?
Eh?
I don't know where it is.
Oh!
I see it down here.
Ah.
I thought it was one of these places on the water.
Nice.
oh my gosh we're like literal cents away it's night oh my
god okay wait maybe we can take like a tiny job no i should
take a big job i need more money we are so close we're now
we're in dampton i could do dampton to wait do dampton to
dampton yeah yeah yeah start job pick up from easy cafe I
guess I could have done to Clifton, but whatever.
Where is it?
Easy cafe.
Over here, right?
Depot.
Bakery.
Oh, it's up there!
Oh, I missed it.
Hold on, I'm getting my bearings.
Yes, I must go straight.
Hey, Minky.
Hello!
The road to $100.
We're so close.
I'm going to forget about the rod for now.
I'm not even going to think about it.
It's over here, right?
Easy, cafe.
Yeah, it's so much money.
The rod.
Me don't know money.
That's me.
Fancy seeing you here.
Oh my gosh.
Are you gonna...
If we were binary code, I'd be a zero because you're the
only one I need.
That's how binary works, right?
Sure.
Is it a fishing minigame that you get when you...
All right, let's see.
Where am I at?
We were what?
Around here?
Like a shortcut.
What do you mean a cooler car?
This is a K truck.
It's like, oh, that's what we need.
Oh.
Let's go.
This is all we need.
Everybody!
Two.
Oh, my goodness.
And we have a little despair.
in case I need, I think I still have, um, I still have one
cup of coffee, I'm pretty sure.
Alright, it's a snowstorm, but no worries.
Maybe we'll get big buck deliveries after this.
Everything will be good.
I hope so.
Oh, everything's not good.
You just had to add the fa- Oh no.
This way.
Oh, wrong way.
Here I thought we were going to get eaten up by...
By, uh...
You know.
The water.
Sick tricks.
Thank you.
I'm full of them?
I'm full of them.
Where am I?
Oh, I don't recognize this area.
Okay, here we go.
What?
Yes.
Alright, we're right here.
I'm full of sick and I'm full of tricks.
And by sick, I mean sick in the head.
Give me that bumper bar.
Give it to me.
Oh?
Hey, not Seb, guys.
Wait, what is he gonna tell us?
I'm remembering.
I put some more air in those tires if I were you.
Actually, never mind.
We're all out of air.
Bumper bars.
These will let you smash through things.
That will cost...
Oh, it's painful.
No air.
Breathing no air.
No air, no air, no air.
What am I supposed to do with these again?
I did it.
Infiltrate the hydro dam in Fishing Town and retrieve the
supplies.
Oh, where is that?
Oh, wait.
Let's have our last thing of coffee.
How do I recycle these cans, then?
Wait, so I can smash their trees and things?
Oh, liars.
Just kidding.
We're taking them out.
Taking them out.
Uh.
Now where is the place I need to go?
Is it the tunnel?
Maybe.
Your driving gives me war flashbacks of Chicago joke.
Maybe here.
Tunnel to.
Oh.
Uh.
Probably.
to them, damn.
Tunnel to...
Oh, Mountain Town!
Wait!
Could I have gotten back to Mountain Town this whole time?
No.
Oh, okay, okay.
Oh!
That would have been so...
horrible.
Shortcut.
I'm unstoppable!
I think this is taking us to Smalton.
And then we can bash through.
Yeah.
And get to Damton.
I wonder if the Damton...
Oh, I wonder if in between that gate is where we need to go.
Probably.
Oh, probably.
I was thinking for some reason that it was Oh, it's hard to
say That maybe It like was just There was nothing in between
But there probably is something in between these guys Yeah,
oh, that was a little tough
Yeah, oh, I think I'm here Enter
Sick flip Thank you.
Yeah, we stuck that landing.
Checks, max.
Welcome to Babusha.
Thank you.
Through the fence, baby.
Oh, yeah.
La, la, la, la, la.
What if it's like the downstairs that I see when I die?
What if?
Oh, what's happening?
I'm scared.
It was a little unnerving down here.
Oh, it's a little spooky.
You guys know that gif of, like, that bunny cat character
that's, like...
That's, like, walking with a lighter or something through a
cave.
That's what, honestly, I thought this game reminded me of.
Hello?
Wait, am I gonna give this to a friend?
Go in?
Hello?
Uh, hello?
It's what I was thinking, too.
Yeah, yeah.
Um.
It's 12 a.m.
Yeah, and the time isn't changing.
Oh, hello.
Uh, hi.
Welcome back, Sombusters.
Thank you very much.
This has dog facing the dark doorway vibes.
Ew!
Oh, there we go.
Fine.
It's important to let me enter before.
That's a good old DFT.
Welcome back.
Thank you!
Why is the time not moving?
There was a path on the bottom screen?
There was!
Wait, was there?
Did I miss it?
Bring up the supplies to MK at the security gate.
I think it's just the walkie because that's what it shows.
I think that's it.
Oh, I'm so glad that the weather is cleared up.
It's so hard to see.
I'll be having a good Christmas.
You too, Artemis.
Thank you.
Thank you for 14 months.
Thank you, thank you.
The walkies.
Love the goose shirt.
I hate the ghost.
Goost.
Talk to me, Goost.
Wait.
Go back, go back, go back.
Beep.
Go Clifton.
Never play Bioshock.
I haven't.
That's another class.
Actually, I'm going to add that to my list.
Because that's another classic game that I've, like, always
wanted to play.
So many classics.
Never played at the time.
Bioshock playthrough.
Yeah, I added to the list of beep, beep, beep of all the
other games that I've...
Oh, oh, oh, no, no, no, no, no, backwards, backwards,
backwards, backwards, backwards, backwards, backwards,
backwards, backwards, backwards, backwards.
Okay, we're okay.
Yeah.
Tunnel of love.
Lord of shadows, welcome to Prambusha.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
Hello!
Great.
You've got the handheld radios.
I just finished with the gate.
It'll stay open for good now.
Yay!
Hearing Bioshock called Classic.
That day, baby.
Hitching to a gift.
Twenty months of it already feels like yesterday.
Thank you so much, legendary tilapia.
Thank you.
Mmm, tilapia, yummy.
Happy holiday, mint.
Oh, we'll be on a good one.
You too, Shadow Demon Lord.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you so much.
Jesse!
Thank you for the five gift.
Thank you for your help so far.
I guess I owe you an explanation.
There's something wrong with the shopkeepers every day that
passes they seem to be getting more ill oh gosh their brain
rotted it's gotten a lot worse since you started the
deliveries again don't worry I don't blame you they've grown
so much since you started and you've given them all a reason
to keep going and to keep me going I know a way to help them
it's not perfect but at least they'll be there they'll be
here i need you to get those ice chains oh no how much do
they cost
okay how do they how much do they cost the ice chains at the
easy auto here we need them to get into that factory i'll
beat you there it's just through the tunnel in weston oh my
gosh my eyes hold on i'm gonna do some eye drops real quick
my ectoplasm is drying out
Good luck out there.
How much do you think they're going to be?
200?
Well, we can't get the big jobs now, so...
I think it'll be okay.
Can I help keep your grip on ice?
Okay.
Let's go get some big...
Wait, let's do a job right now.
Jobs.
Snowy peaks.
That's pretty fun.
Okay, we have to go to Snowy Peaks For the big job Snowy
Peaks to where
Pick up a Snowy Peaks Whatever Pick up from Izimara Snowy,
okay I don't remember like any other place anymore
I don't know what the location like anymore.
It's been so long.
Okay, right now we're in Easton?
Mount...
Where are we?
Pick up from...
Oh!
Wait, why did I get out?
You've worked here for 20 years.
Bro!
Welcome back!
Thank you so much!
Oh, man.
From here to snowy peaks.
Oh, okay, okay, okay, okay.
So, where is it at?
Pick up from EZMR.
Oh, oh!
My car!
Um, am I gonna die?
Um.
Where's my car?
Oh, okay, thank goodness.
Oh, down here.
Okay, so we have to go back to Clifton.
While eating pumpkin pie.
I want pumpkin pie.
Oh, I want pumpkin pie.
Okay, Clifton is not far.
Mmm, pumpkin pie.
Wait, this is like such a long delivery.
Okay, but we only have to do a couple of them maybe.
And Easy Mart is...
Here!
Do, rift, do!
Have you had a sweet potato pie?
Okay, yes, but...
Hey, mate.
I've been training myself to eliminate...
Chlorofluorocarbons from the air I breathe.
So that I can begin to repair the ozone layer.
Can I buy...
Okay, no.
I'm gonna need more coffee soon.
For now, though, I'm okay.
Uh-oh.
Am I gonna lose my payload?
Nah, we're fine.
Everyone, go watch chat.
Where's my car?
Stop.
Thank you for the silver chat, boy.
Quit it.
Oh, we just lost another one.
Don't worry about it.
though.
Tunnel of love this way.
Why don't we have a radio anymore?
What happened?
I miss our...
I miss our radio.
Wait, am I going the right way?
Please say yes.
Yes.
Tunnel of love.
Okay, get ready for smooch-in!
It's over.
Alright, so now we're going up here.
to Upton.
We're in Easton.
It's an Upton drive.
We got to deliver over there.
Oh.
It's really, really far away.
It's gonna take us a couple of days.
and up to 10 drive.
This way.
Wait, what is that tunnel to Fishing Town?
Where does that lead to?
Is there a second tunnel?
Hmm.
Whatever.
We're here.
We just grazed it.
Fishing Town.
Fishing Towns, yeah, where it just came from.
But that's why I was like, wait a second.
Shortcut!
Keep going, come on, shift gear.
One to two, two to three, three to four, four to five!
Maximum gears!
Maximum power!
As long as we don't lose our cargo, we're okay.
She's shifting it?
I'm shifting it!
They call me the anamorph.
Unlimited power!
Where am I anyway?
Oh wait, we're almost there.
This is the radio tower.
Right?
Are there multiple endings to this game?
Uh oh.
Oh, I thought we were gonna lose it.
I thought we were Losing it.
Fifth gear on a snowy uphill.
Don't worry about it.
Kick it into high gear.
We've got snow boots on.
Snow tires on.
Okay, I think now we're in Upton, yes.
Very good.
If I keep going, yes.
You're not worried?
Good because I'm not worried.
If you're not worried, I'm not worried.
I wish we had our radio back on, though.
It has a story I missed.
It's like, yes and no.
It's kind of just like what the dog talked about earlier.
Like, the people, the villagers are kind of weird.
But for the most part, we've just been making deliveries.
Okay, I gotta be careful here.
I gotta be very, very careful.
Yes.
Oh, I didn't see where I'm delivering this
Wait Where am I?
Wait, where am I?
I have to go to mountain Yes And then
Pretty chill and yop game I kind of wanted that I just
wanted something like How we could chill and yop to Yeah And
just kind of hang out for a bit, you know.
Oh!
Sorry.
Ah, pick up the payload.
Ah, we're losing some money, guys.
Oh, no.
Oh, no, no, no.
Oh, we're dead.
We're dead.
Everybody, it's so over.
Oh, shoot.
It's over for us?
It's over for us.
Oh, my gosh.
We might make it
Meant over Never be game over I don't have any coffee
Never be meant over How have you guys been though?
Did you guys get anything nice for Christmas That you liked?
Like tell me about your if you celebrate and everything.
Tell me about your holiday or anything.
Got a record player.
Let's go.
I got Minto for Christmas.
What does that mean?
I wasn't told about this.
Switch 2?
Ristwatch.
Piss 5.
You got nothing?
It's okay.
Me too.
Well, kind of.
Like, my mom got me a little bit of skincare, but...
She got me some, like, face masks.
So I didn't get nothing, nothing, but, you know.
Small amount.
Socks, which I wanted.
Let's go.
Copy of Delta.
Taco Bell gift card.
I love that for you.
So Taco Bell is on you, then.
I got a pack of M&Ms as a gag.
And $200!
Whoa!
Okay.
Coffee powder.
Let's get this.
Ace Attorney Investigation I got these cute headphones and I
bought myself a Steam Deck Oh nice A Steam Deck I want a
Steam Deck
I'm not good with handheld stuff Like I have Switch But I I
just I just don't use them you know It's so weird because I
was so into my game I like grew up with handheld like I grew
up with Game Boy and like DS and everything but I nowadays
I'm like PC or nothing I don't know so strange 3DS is the
only handheld I still use I don't know what it is like I
like I guess I could put my I could put my switch on the
dock and play it on the TV but hmm phone has replaced I
guess I'll say it, maybe.
Tell SD49 error.
Ellie, SD49 error.
I look.
SD49 error.
Love them so.
State 49, 20, 77, 69, 60, 60, 20.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
That will cost $6.98.
I'll just be here.
This is so sad!
He loves her.
I have no energy.
No, let's just buy an energy drink to the land.
Energy!
Okay.
Alright, let's get another job.
Fishing town.
Oh, $71 though!
$81!
Wait, so I pick up...
I pick up here.
here and take it to Fishing Town.
Oh my gosh, that's basically what we just did now.
But $81 is huge.
Let's take it.
Pick up from Easy Auto.
Oh, my gas too, though.
I have the same experience with handhelds like the Switch
and even 3DS.
Right, there it goes.
I guess I want you to say, oh my god, that's so much worth
it.
Come to the conclusion that in adult life, I'm not stranded
somewhere waiting for a ride or being driven somewhere.
You know what?
That makes so much sense.
That does make a lot of sense.
Easy, Otto.
But where am I currently?
I think that...
Yeah.
It's not here, is it?
No.
Oh, wait.
Maybe I'm at Lopton.
Just kidding.
Okay, we gotta go to Monton.
I'm getting confused where I'm at.
My brain is not doing well with these locations.
At the moment.
Okay.
That makes a lot of sense.
Yeah, I never thought of it that way.
And then, but honestly, like, phones do, I feel, replace.
Oh, wait.
Replace so much, too.
Like, I find myself, you know, rather than...
Being like, oh, I'll play a game.
I'm doom scrolling.
On some app.
On the.
The children's app.
The app that makes my brain stupid.
Too busy playing B.A.
Exactly.
Gotta do my dailies.
That makes my brain stupid too.
My brain think of only anime girl.
While driving.
Absolutely.
Want to get a flip phone.
Oh, not like an actual flip phone.
Not like the gimmicky like the Samsung flip or anything.
You want to get like a straight...
You want to get the old person's phone.
The ones that have no apps on them.
Because old people don't know how they work.
Where am I?
I'm up here, aren't I?
How did I miss this?
Okay, if I go this...
Okay, this is what we're gonna do.
Watch this.
I'm breaking the map.
Okay, I think I'm here.
Get a jitterbug!
That's what I was thinking!
MGS Peace Walker was more portable.
Got the weapon!
I didn't think I'd be able to catch you live today.
Welcome back.
How's the trucking going?
We're trucking along!
Just like that.
Thank you for the pink!
There it is.
Right?
Yes.
Oh no, I need more energy again.
I remember Seb was talking about retiring.
But they would still come here, up here every day with MK
just to visit.
Made me feel special, you know?
Okay, we gotta go make some coffee.
Wait.
Close.
There we go.
Minty Sweat.
Welcome back.
Thank you.
What was that about K-Truck's not being safe enough for the
U.S.?
They seem plenty safe to me.
You know what?
I will eat my words.
This thing has gone through it.
And it is definitely 100% realistic representation of a real
K-Truck.
It is not accordioned once.
It's blown up.
But what car does it blow up nowadays, am I right?
Oh my gosh, Gilgamesh!
Thank you so much for that video!
Thank you!
Uh-oh.
Uh-oh, we have really low energy.
Okay, we're fine.
Let her cook.
Every car explodes!
Yeah!
Wait, oh.
Where is it?
Wait, where'd that cup of coffee go?
Wait.
Oh, okay, there it is.
Oh, I was so scared for a second.
Okay.
Awesome.
Now we're going to Fishing Town.
It's really weird that the teleport back to the street
feature isn't standard across all cars.
You know, that is a standard feature we need and also um
uh also uh
rear view mirrors I mean cameras sorry
I don't know why dashcams aren't like integrated into cars
nowadays it makes me mad that I have to go buy a dash cam.
All cars at this point should just have dash cams built in.
It's so annoying.
So we're in Upton.
If I go, if I just go, if I just run off the side of the
road.
Uh-oh.
Oh, package!
Oh package!
Oh package, my package, oh where could you be?
Somewhere resting among the trees.
Oh package, my package, oh where are thee?
I'm looking for you, my package.
Um, what about my drive?
Wait, if I reset, come back to me.
Dang it.
Oh, package, my package, oh, where are thee?
Oh, package, my package, I can't believe you'd leave me
tonight.
Where is it?
Uh-oh.
What if it's all the way up there?
Check the map.
Can I give up on this job?
I can't give up on the job.
And low on gas?
I am!
Oh my gosh!
We gotta get to Easton.
I respect you trying to speedrun strat this game.
Thank you.
Where am I going?
Where am I, anyway?
I'm gonna give up?
No, my big money.
My big money job.
Oh, this one's an Eastern.
Okay, start job.
Easy auto.
Okay, okay, okay.
Uh.
Where am I, anyway?
Let's just keep going down.
I'll make it.
One more try.
Okay, Don't spin around.
Don't do that.
Okay, let's try it one more time.
A little bit, a little bit of a, you know.
Just finished my three days.
Tokyo, Disney, then.
See, I had a great time with my family.
Shit's so there.
Tell me everything.
Did you do Journey to the Center of the Earth?
Did you like it?
Did you love it?
Was it the best ride ever?
Was it so much fun?
Maybe not best ride ever.
But, did you have, did you like it?
Where am I picking up from?
Easy, Otto.
Where is that?
Oh, okay.
It was bid.
Shut up!
Humph.
If Easy, Cole offered mental health service benefits, I'd
tell my therapist about you.
You're lucky they don't offer benefits at all.
A part of me wants to give up on this game.
I'm not going to lie.
Part of me wants to rage quit right now.
A part of me really wants to rage quit.
Every time
I see you in that truck, I think it's Seb.
Seb told me something the last time I saw them, but I still
can't remember.
I missed them.
What is going...
There's like an arrow over here.
Maybe it's just like the chat or the,
you know.
Where am I going?
Snowy peaks.
It's like too easy to lose all the money in this game.
I mean, okay, I will accept fault for the last, you know,
having to give up on the last mission.
was my fault.
But!
I just need, like, one!
I just need, I just need $100 jobs, please!
It's, the game is just a little too tedious.
Oh, wait.
I went the wrong way.
Oh my gosh.
This way.
Goro, thank you so much for the rhythm work.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
It's fine.
We're chilling.
The shortcuts are so tempting.
I know.
Maybe they should add cargo straps.
I know!
Paperback, thank you so much for the gifted.
Thank you.
Wrong, forever.
Thank you so much for the five gifted.
Thank you.
Upton.
Okay, I'll play it straight.
I'll play it fair.
I'll play it as the game intends you to play.
I'll do it.
I'll do it properly.
Faithless, thank you so much for the 20 gift.
Thank you.
Is that what the duct tape is for?
No way.
Do you think?
Okay, thank you so much for the gift.
Thank you.
Cargo straps.
That'll be $500.
I don't want to think about how much money we just...
Oh my gosh.
Just to fill up.
And we didn't even fill up all the way.
Why?
Maybe the...
It has to be that...
It was like more expensive there than other gas stations.
It's like real life for real.
Terrible.
They're like, yeah, this place is so expensive.
Because it's in the city.
One in Smolton was way cheaper.
Yeah, exactly.
That's why I was so...
Maybe because you get smaller dollars.
Kitty, I was thinking so much before the five gets there.
Oh.
La,
la, la.
Oh, no.
Please, no.
We're fine.
Okay, welcome to Mountain Town.
Phil, make us over here that they're gifted.
Thank you guys for all the gifted memberships.
I really appreciate it.
I missed the radio, too.
I think that's what's making me feel like...
Wait, what's...
One second.
Okay, never mind.
Wait, one second.
Okay, there we go.
Where are we delivering this to?
All the way to Lopton again.
Okay, okay.
It's depressing without the radio.
Does someone know how I can change it?
I think I asked before.
Maybe I missed the answer.
Controls in the menu.
Let's see.
Radio.
Oh!
Radio on!
Wait, but it is on.
Okay, let's...
What's scan?
Okay, up a scan.
Oh!
Oh.
We got the news.
There we go.
Wait, hold on.
I must read.
Journey was so fun.
Thunder Mountain was thrilling to me.
My mom really liked Beauty and the Beast.
I didn't expect the animatronics to look so smooth.
Beauty and the Beast is awesome.
It's so good.
Oh.
Okay, now it won't stop scanning.
Pick a channel.
Okay.
there we go okay we're good
we're vibing
do you guys like driving maybe it's because I don't like
driving not like I don't mind this like driving games but
I do enjoy driving at night though that's the only time I
think I like driving like peak driving is driving at night
like down it's nice cool weather there's not many people out
that's like my favorite time to drive too stressful I know I
know some people though that like just like driving no
matter what you know what power to you could not be me I'm
low on energy.
Oh.
Meem-y-o!
Energy!
Get on.
Alright, we got 55 bucks.
I like riding more.
Oh, I like riding, too.
I love being a passenger princess.
Fishing town!
Big money.
Okay.
Guys, we won't mess this one up.
I pick up all the way over there.
I love being a passenger princess.
No cargo loss.
Woohoo!
A shortcut.
I could shortcut through here.
Come on.
Knock down the trees.
There we go.
Can't wait for the next skip tech I'm gonna learn.
I'm just a tutorial channel.
This would have been so tedious without those upgrades.
I think the upgrades though, they force you.
Kind of can't continue the game without them.
Minto already is our princess.
I'm not a princess, I'm the maid.
I can't be the princess.
I'm serving the princess.
Kindred, welcome to... membership, thank you!
Okay, we're here.
Definitely serving.
I'm serving and I'm slaying.
And I'm possessing.
And I'm crying.
Just ghost things.
You think I can shortcut here?
Oh.
Tip number 55.
An easy delivery code?
You cannot.
Shortcut at that corner.
Are you saying I'm a princess?
Yes, you're my princess.
Shortcut!
I mean, though I'm not a princess.
Yeah, wait.
Isn't the flower shop here?
My dad bought me a gamer subs cup for Christmas.
I literally screamed.
It says, thank you!
Oh, there it is.
Multi-hour drives along mostly empty roads with nothing but
farm fields and an occasional house on them is a meditative
experience.
I love it.
Yes!
I get it though!
I know some people are like, oh my gosh, I hate driving like
one long, like straight road with nothing around, but I'm
like, that's what I crave.
I crave!
Oh my god!
Good greetings.
I have feelings.
Several of them.
This is new to me.
I feel happy about this.
Do you have feelings?
I will be your feelings.
What?
What do you mean you'll be my feelings?
I think I have feelings.
Like I'm feeling annoyed.
All right.
Good one.
Thanks.
Finally, you guys like my jokes.
Finally.
I will be your feelings is really cute, though.
Yeah, I like them.
Pencil!
Oh my gosh, thank you so much for the office.
Can you be mega boss, Princess Queen?
And say, yeah.
Thank
you so much for that, Kaisupa.
Thank you!
Funny request.
Woo!
Okay, we're fine.
Everything's good.
All right, fishing town.
The proper way.
Not the proper way.
Merry Christmas, Mito!
I like driving by hate traffic.
Yeah.
I don't think anybody likes traffic, though.
Except, okay.
Sometimes I would get stuck in traffic.
And if I was listening to a podcast I really liked, I would
be okay with it.
You know what I mean?
I would be like, oh yeah, I want to finish this episode of
my podcast.
So I would be like, it's fine that there's traffic.
Creepcast.
What's that?
stores same with oh yes with audio books too yes yes yes
hard time is when I get to do most of my singing I will do
that too I like practice songs oh sorry in the car no I
wonder if I'm almost done with this game I think maybe just
a few more quests because it seems like if I like go to the
quest and the goals It seems like there's just three more
maybe.
Put your karaoke streams on for my four hour plus drives!
That's so embarrassing.
Why do you guys watch me?
Why do you guys listen to me?
What's it?
Why?
Sometimes listen to your VODs.
Come here.
Does this, is this a, this is, oh my gosh, wait, I'm
commuting and you're listening to this VOD while you're
commuting and yeah, I'm commuting with your commute.
Minto goes on the speakers.
Scary.
That's some real haunting right there.
Please watching a Minto stream.
We're flying Japan.
I'm so sorry!
2026 will be your year.
Merry Christmas, Happy New Year!
Please don't send a Zuber chat if you can.
If you lost your job, don't do that.
Save your money, especially also, you're going to Japan.
Wait, can we shortcut here?
Okay, shortcut, but like, legitimate.
Uh-oh, not legitimate.
Oh!
Pinto funny and good storyteller.
You think so?
You aren't seeing the parts of Minky.
What do you mean?
Holy cow.
Guys, we did that.
Where am I anyway?
To Eastern.
Okay.
I want to see where that other...
Where the other...
tunnel window.
You know?
Is this the one?
Oh, I think it's just a side road.
Okay, I think they both lead to the same tunnel.
I think.
Oh my gosh.
I'm too good at my job.
Maybe.
Oh my god.
No, we're on half a tank of fuel.
We're all good.
Alright, where are we going to?
All the way up to the corner.
Holy cow.
Yeah, we need coffee though, that's for sure.
What other stations we got?
The news.
Oh, wait.
We'll go with this one.
99.9.
That's my station.
Snow drifting.
You're scaring me, Minto.
I'm a ghost.
That's like partially what I do.
Okay.
That's, like, part of my job.
I'm not gonna lie.
I can't help it.
Skim-setting with all the snowflakes makes me think of
Moomit's episode!
We're Little Vibe's Lady of the Cold!
Oh, my gosh.
I love Moomit so much.
Stop.
You're gonna make me...
There's a 24-hour stream of, like, Moomit episodes that I
just, like...
Sometimes I'll put it on for hours.
I love Moomit.
Literally in the drop description.
Let's just say that all ghosts are spooky.
I think all ghosts are spooky, though.
Are you saying that I'm not spooky and that I'm doing a
terrible job and that I should...
I should just... I should just quit?
Are you... Are you saying that I should just quit while I'm
ahead?
Are you saying I'm not spooky at all and that I'll never
amount to anything in my afterlife?
That I can't scare you!
Well, it's fine.
I'm not like, you know, Monsters Inc., how they live off the
energy of laughter or whatever.
I just live off the energy.
I just, you know.
It doesn't need to be...
I just live off your life for it, so you don't need to be...
You don't even need to believe in me.
You know?
I've already got the...
I've got the upper hand here.
vampire i need to finish what we do in the shadows did
anybody watch that first of all did you watch that show or
did you only see the movie and if one or the other if you
saw the show did you like the ending tell me if the ending
was good or not i've seen clips i love that show never heard
of it actually it's like the office meets vampires like
that's literally it.
Oh, shoot, my energy.
Wait, I think I'll die here.
Okay, get in.
We're gonna get in real quick.
Ending was good?
I admittedly ran out of steam in the last couple seasons.
I have a few really good seasons.
Yeah, that's the thing, as I also, like, kind of just, like,
I don't know.
I think I, it was kind of like, this happens to me way too
often, where I'll be like super into a series and then it'll
take a long time in between seasons and I just run it's not
that I run out of interest but like you know maybe I'm busy
maybe something you know you've actually jump scared me a
couple of times so feel proud of that I don't know if I
should feel proud of that or not yeah you find other things
or you're just It's like working on other stuff, you know.
Alright, 2.99.
We're nearly halfway there.
Oh, we're almost halfway there.
Oh, Snowy Peaks, $87.
We're picking up in Clifton.
That's fine, because we have to basically go back down there
to get out of here anyway.
Lemon on a pair.
terrible at watching stuff or finishing stuff just because
my interest drops it's really like with whistle word with
series that like I said they take forever to do another
season like that's when I'll fall off like my truck here
nice save watching you cries scares you I don't cry so much
Why?
Maybe I am a bit of a cry, baby.
Maybe I cry a lot.
Maybe.
But that's also, like, just ghost things, you know?
I wouldn't be a ghost if I wasn't filled with such regret
and despair and pain.
That's why I say, being a ghost, so overriding.
A little bit is a charm point.
Stupid cry, baby.
I did cry recently.
I cried about dinosaur ride ending.
I cried about dinosaur ride.
You guys think I should get gas here in Smolton?
You almost cried about movement just now.
Shut up, shut up, shut up!
You cried this about dinosaurs shut up shut up the birds
they run away when i approach them they know i'm on to them
i don't think they're real oh no it's one of these
yeah i don't think i will last if i don't get gas here in
smelton we'll do that we'll do that
And there they go.
Oh, wait.
Beep.
Weep.
I love my sappy cry by Beyoshi.
Nobody should be surprised.
What is a dinosaur if not a lizard?
Oh, my gosh.
That was the best part about Florida.
There, you guys.
There were so many lizards.
In Florida, they would just be running around.
Looking extra cute tonight.
Still.
I have work in the morning.
5 a.m.
I'm sure Sneaks up fast.
Good night!
Am I going the right way?
Yes.
To Smalton.
To Dampton.
Okay, Smalton time.
Half of them are invasive, though.
Don't, wait, seriously?
What are the... What are the lizards, though?
What, like, what are they called?
What kind of lizards are they?
I cried for the first time in years after watching you play
The Walking Dead.
Oh my gosh, that made me cry too though.
Dinosaurs are more birds than lizards though.
I like birds too though.
I like...
Anolis.
Lots...
I like when they...
Okay.
I'm gonna demonstrate what they do.
When you see the lizard and they're standing there and then
they start going like this.
I like when they do that.
Or when the red thing comes out of their neck.
all right let's go get our gas
we'll have to take on more jobs but oh what's another couple
back and forth huh
i can't really think of what i want for christmas so i got
mostly money this year oh a quarter went into blue archive
what'd you get did you get anything good Merry Christmas,
Min.
Merry Christmas!
No, I know, thank you.
Gamble safely.
The head bob is them intimidating you.
I know, but it's so funny.
It's not intimidating at all.
It's just so cute.
Oh, wait.
I'm heading to pizza.
I saw lizards at Hallmat and thought of you.
I've gotten several people sending me, like, pictures of
lizards and things and being, like...
of you.
It's like the best thing ever.
I love it so much when people like tag me and things being
like, thinking of you.
Or send me things.
It's the best ever.
Weirder dragons sometimes wave their hands.
But they're too cute.
They're way too cute.
more coffee, do I?
I do not.
Yikes.
You know, Bucko, you're starting to grow on me.
No way!
Character development?
Here's 2850.
Just kidding.
It's the opposite.
Oh, it's opposite thing.
Pay up.
Now go away.
2850, though.
That's way better.
I'm gonna grab another one even.
Uh-oh.
Oh shoot.
I didn't realize how bad I was going in cold.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Get in.
Okay, we're fine.
Why is he so grumpy?
I think I would be too.
Working in this weather.
Yeesh.
28.50 way better than the highway robbery in Upton.
That's why it's called Upton.
Because the prices are up a ton.
You get it?
They're up, Todd.
I don't know how to recycle the cans.
I wish I could figure it out.
Are you proud of that one?
You don't think it was good?
You don't think so?
Why did I actually like that pun?
I went to your home at the other weekend.
It was wonderful.
I had to ask if you put...
I had to ask you to put you on a small retuber and you I
gave a great recommendation.
I'm glad you like her.
Chocolate pie eater, welcome back.
Thank you for coming to see me.
Thank you.
Yeah, I'm smiling.
All right, where are we going to?
Snowy peaks again.
Probably the very...
Why can't anything, like, be a close spot?
Axel Valentine, welcome to Mambuja.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
I'm determined to beat this game today.
You're banned from making puns ever again.
You guys hate me.
You hate me.
I am filled with determination.
I'm also just happy to stream.
Sorry that I had no schedule this week.
But of course next week we will return to our regular game.
schedule the programming?
Whoa.
Wait, hold on.
Oh, sorry.
Oh my gosh.
The interface sometimes gives me, like, a whiplash.
I like to give them ant farms, butterfly cages, and pregnant
as egg sacks for Christmas.
By the time the children has gifts, it's too late for the
parent to refuse.
Wait, but that's so awesome.
You're giving them the gift of responsibility.
An ant farm I want an ant farm even now is it are they tough
to manage oh I was fixing my eye I
remember raising butterflies when I was a kid wait oh gosh
okay I couldn't see anything everything's fine don't mind
the broken pot I'm still an excellent delivery driver.
One of the best in the biz.
Just remember to give him some food.
With the ants?
I'll give him a sugar cube.
Oh, my ants would be eating good.
I'm going to give my ants A5 Wagyu.
Wait.
You have a PL box.
I will.
soon.
Ten-tsutsu!
Staff-san are setting it up for us.
But I don't know if you can- I don't know if you should send
ads in the mail.
I don't know if that one will make it through, Chief right?
I think that one might give me tone.
But I appreciate it.
I can imagine the message now just being like Hey Mint We
received something in the mail for you I'm not sure how you
feel about it It's just an envelope of ants
Like they're crawling out and everything Just put them in
the envelope with like a the apple pit.
Oops, all ants.
Yeah, maybe don't send ants to the PO box.
Rain of ants.
You can buy a starter colony.
One thing I really want to learn to get good at, well, this
isn't with ants, but with bees, I want to learn how to
identify the queen.
I like to watch those videos of, like, people um rescuing
bees in like places like you know just kind of like trying
to move the nest to a to a nicer to a better place and
things like that and so easily they'll be like okay i have
to find the queen and like they'll they'll find it usually
so easily i'm like how do you know
Bekeeper Minto Ark.
If I had time and place for beekeeping, I would.
You can send all kinds of things in unmarked boxes.
Don't send ladybugs, I would cry.
Of terror.
Sorry, berry bugs.
Monitor lizards by mail, too.
How?
How do you get a lizard in the mail?
What do you put them to say?
sleep?
I think you'd give him a little bit of a snacky snack to
make him close his eyes for a couple extra hours and
ladybug scare me.
Turmite queen looks crazy.
Really?
Why?
They like beefy?
Reptiles can actually be shipped responsibly.
It just costs a lot.
I see.
Alright, where are we headed to?
Oh!
Muntin, all the way in the corner.
Don't mind the stuff falling.
It will all be delivered safely.
Oh, gosh.
This last bit is kind of torturous.
Maybe I should have saved my money better.
I should have done more missions.
Me identifying queen.
I can't be the queen.
I can't be queen and meruos.
Ants are off the table.
What about sea monkeys?
Those, I just need to rehydrate, right?
I just put those guys in water and they grow.
I'm gonna have a zoo in my maid cafe.
You guys are gonna send me all sorts of creatures and
critters.
I've heard of issues where people will get things for
their...
like fish tanks and oh my gosh and it'll be like dried rocks
or something you know and they don't realize that there's
that there's worms in there like a dehydrated worm or
something and it'll revive and and I've seen things where
like they'll be like hey my fish started going missing
what's happening and they'll be like check for the worm
there might be a worm hidden amongst the sand that is eating
your fish or something like that isn't that so crazy you
have common what what mullin growing in my backyard ladybugs
love it no
aquarium worms terrify me yeah the bobbin worms yes yes yes
that's a That's exactly it.
Nothing more classic than a water ball for fish.
Water ball, what's that?
I wanna send you prints of the photos, I think.
See more, I was going through them, the ones that you gave
me at home at.
I love them so much.
Thank you.
You're, you're, you're, you're, your, your photos are so
great.
I wanna start like making a, like a, I guess I really do
need to buy a photo album for kind of, I want to like
remember events and stuff that I've done with the pictures
that people, like I have a bunch of, sometimes people will
send me checkies and stuff.
And so I have a bunch of checkies of, from events that are
in my checkie albums.
Oh wait.
Open, grab, and place.
And get in.
Hi, have an easy day!
Okie dokie!
I'm going to buy more coffee.
That's easy March.
We're almost there.
We're sure getting there somehow.
Hey mate.
I'm gonna start by a camera to start making checkies.
Or you could always get like a portable printer, checky
printer, if you don't want to buy the whole camera.
If you have time on Friday night, I host a book club at
Sixos.
I'm the only one who knows it's a book club.
But it's wonderful to just spend time with my new friends.
That's so cute.
That will cost $7.
Cheers.
Thank you.
And...
What does the duct tape do?
And the bird seed.
Wait, the bird seed for the birds.
Do you think I should make a fire?
Wait, I mean...
Actually...
I'm by...
I'm by the cabin.
We'll just go make some coffee in there.
What was the point of me buying this dang coffee pot if I'm
not buying the firewood to use it?
I'm what?
What did I say that?
Okay, let's get another job.
Mountain town, mountain town.
Fishing town.
We feed caterpillars, plants they don't normally live on.
The butterflies that become horribly mutated.
Ew!
Oh gosh, that's creepy.
$55, but mountain town.
Let's take that.
We gotta go to Winton, though.
Okay.
Pick up from bar.
Alright, let's go get it.
It's just like bam.
If I'm going down, I'm taking these trees with me.
Oh, I went down.
Do you lose money when you...
When that happens?
No?
Okay, good.
See, everything's fine.
Free unlimited kit trucks.
Yubi!
I don't quite know where we...
Oh, I think I know.
Uh, we're gonna explode.
No, we're not.
No, we're winning.
We're winning.
Wait, where am I?
Oh.
Alright, here we go.
Wait.
Five big booms!
Boom, boom, boom!
Boom!
Speed running is always the answer.
Let's make the coffee here.
At the cabin.
I feel like trucks weren't really meant to roll like that.
I don't know what you're talking about.
That's like literally the tech for the KT.
trucks if k trucks come to america now you know how to oops
now you know how to properly drive one
coffee powder hook
it's more efficient exactly editors don't please do not
actually drive k trucks like that
oh wait do i have an extra cam
I'm gonna have this bad boy.
K is for crazy.
Crazy driving.
Alright.
We're going to Winton.
Wait, where's the pickup?
Oh, I thought the pickup was at Winton.
I'm so stupid!
Guys, I made a grave mistake.
Happy to spend another birthday watching my car.
I'm using Jacob!
Happy birthday!
Thank you so much for today's comfy stream.
It is pretty comfy, isn't it?
We're just driving around.
I'm doing flips and tricks.
You guys are watching my sick moves.
Oh, there we go.
Thank you saying, Winton is the best thing I've heard.
Why?
Winton.
All right, over the...
Okay.
Oops.
I kind of...
Very sick moves, terminal even.
No, we're alive.
We're alive and well.
Everything's good.
Everything's chill.
Everything's cool.
We're in the bar, right?
I think so.
Oh, oops.
Yo!
I have a huge business idea for you.
Picture a vending machine that sold other things.
They're vending machines.
Great, eh?
Thank you.
Oh.
I almost messed that up already.
I almost already messed up.
Now where are we going?
Oh, the delivery!
Is in Mountain Town.
Not in Winton.
It's not Winton, everybody.
It's Mountain Town.
Tuna?
What did I just say?
No Winton.
The only way is if vending machines sell vending machines to
other vending machines.
Yes.
Shame.
Minton.
Oh my gosh.
Minton MM.
Flip it around.
Winton win.
The birds are fake.
The snow is fake.
The beer is fake.
And the car is fake.
But you know what's not fake about this?
My awesome skills.
I'm driving on the road.
The road is fake.
This sign is fake and the trees are fake.
But you know what's not fake about this?
My love for you.
Wait, the beer is fake?
I'm so sorry.
I imagine you would drive like this IRL.
Maybe.
Put me in.
Put me behind a wheel, coach.
Alright.
Where are we headed to?
Eastend.
Right by our fuel delivery.
Guys, we...
After this, we'll be so close to...
We could just take on an easy job.
An electric light bulb and a video game is still an electric
light bulb.
Nah.
Why are there only birds?
I don't mind.
I love birds, but I need a drink.
Yeah.
Doki bird.
Logically little tubby crows.
Are you calling doki tubby?
Uh-oh, doki bird.
You need to go on a diet.
Diet bird.
I thought chubby was in though.
No?
Mito, cute!
Mito, sweet!
Thank you!
We love chubby.
Yeah, I thought chubby was in.
It's not, it's not, it's, I mean, it's chub, but it's, it's
literally for the winter.
They must have it.
Catherine, welcome to membership.
Thank you!
Don't, do you ever wish that like humans...
hibernated?
Hi Minto, I love you!
Fro!
Um, Fro, why didn't you send me Christmas raccoon pictures?
What the heck?
sometimes actually don't i wish sometimes like i could eat a
lot of food and get really fat and then sleep and lose it
all in the winter
you do you get it i mean though i love you more tuner pretty
sure my body tries to every winter it's a pain to fight it
that's the dream she wants to hibernate yeah that's what I
said don't you ever wish you could just hibernate I'm
hibernating for the winter it's literally the dream I'm
having right now you don't follow me queen I can't DM you I
do have the power to change that I'll try and remember later
you'd socially miss out on a lot oh gosh can you imagine
waking up and being like what did i miss but like oh my gosh
it would be so weird because like you know half of the i
love you more than tunas he's like what is happening the
girls are fighting
how like the southern hemisphere right now it's summer so so
they would be awake and they would make a bunch of memes and
a bunch of crazy stuff and then you'd wake up like several
months later and you'd be like what happened what
if you want to like go to a place what if you want to go to
okay all right we're almost there guys 2.99 we just need
like a 50 job 50.
what the not enough energy oh wow that's crazy i can i can
make coffee
genetics and whatnot would make hibernating very diverse for
people I want to be a moon man.
I want to sleep.
Okay, snowy peaks.
Weston to snowy peaks.
Let's do it.
Pick up from bar.
Then we can buy whatever the hell they wanted me to get.
And hopefully nothing more ever.
My family lives in a town called Weston.
Yeah, I'm going there right now.
I'm going to go...
Oh, dang it.
I lost it.
I was gonna go say...
I was gonna say I'm going to pick her mom up, but...
I lost it.
Sorry.
My...
Is this the right bar?
I don't think so.
I'll try it anyway.
Sixo keeps trying to pitch everyone their business ideas at
our meetups.
I tried helping to be nice at first, but it's actually just
plain fun to help out my twin.
Okay, wrong one.
You were this close.
I know, I just...
I'm a flop.
I'm a hack, I'm a fraud.
Failed the quick time event.
Where is the bar up here?
Oops.
How did I do that?
The bar!
Oh,
this is the factory that we need to get to.
This raises an interesting question.
Is it the weather that causes hibernation or more hardwired?
Also, the U.S.
National Park Service hosts a FAP...
I do know about FAP, but...
competition thank
you so much for the pink also by the way thank you hello yo
the people in town are getting together more often more
people to pitch myself the leading spam email idea to oh
wait a second that was not a bad one wait the tailgate is
open close
actually cooked.
He's cooking!
Mr. Walter!
Alright, Snowy Peaks.
Well, what if you get a spam that you... is not actually a
spam?
That's pretty bad.
32 fat bear chunk one.
After end of delivery number two, the world was split into
two.
East and Weston.
This marked the beginning of the era known as the Cold
Weather Delivery.
After the end of delivery, too.
We'll split the two.
Oh, so iconic.
You love Spam.
I want some Spam Musubi right now.
I could go for that.
Mmm, Spam Musubi.
Mmm.
Spam was to be loved!
Yeah, it's so good!
Oh, I feel like part of me always wants to like make more
spam dishes, but also I'm like...
The salt.
My ectoplasm would dry the heck out.
Spam grilled cheese!
That's so yummy.
Locomoco Spam I don't think I've ever had Locomoco before
Like I know what it is But I've never had it
Typer bed Thanks so much for staying Good night I don't
think we have much of the game left I'm just vibing honestly
I don't even know how long I've been streaming for What five
hours Ha ha ha Six hours!
Almost!
Mmm, we're vibing.
It's been a while since I've done like a longer stream,
so...
A couple of the games though that I have that I want to
complete for my...
Um...
For my 50 games of the year?
Or a bit longer, so there will be a couple longer streams.
Coming up.
Alright, let's see where are we going.
Mountain!
I like this music too, so I'm like super vibing.
What does the game count at?
I think I have five more games I need to do.
Merry Mentimers.
Thank you, John.
Thank you.
Snowy 9.
Hydration check?
Yes.
Actually, I need to get some more soon.
Isn't spam salty?
Yeah.
That's why I said it's kind of salty.
eat it all the time it's like super salty oh but it's so
yummy oh my gosh like i want to like a spam fried rice or
something sometimes i just want to go to a hibachi place so
i can get fried rice i don't know the last time i've gotten
like a proper hibachi though like a hibachi restaurant
maybe i should stop talking about food
God, I love rice.
You were so right and so real.
Oh, there was...
I was thinking...
What was I thinking of today?
I was thinking of something.
And how, like, just, you know...
Uh...
How rice is just not, like, a super staple...
like American dish.
Spam with Oh wait, hold on.
I have to look at the road.
Spam.
Rice with spam and mayo.
I haven't.
Yeah, we eat.
America loves bread.
Grab it.
And I'm gonna place it!
Uh-oh.
Get in?
We made it!
Oh my gosh!
Now I can go buy this chains from the auto shop.
Where do I get them though?
Any auto shop?
I feel like a lot of Hispanic and Asian dishes require it.
Yeah!
Rice is just so good, it's so versatile, it's perfect.
Nice.
Well done, Minto.
Thank you.
I'm not quite sure where I go.
Any auto shop?
Let's try.
Okay, trucks are so good.
They just roll back on their side.
Wait, I'm going back upstairs.
Just kidding.
Down?
Wait, I think I'm gonna explode.
Never punished.
My family eats so many potatoes.
Okay, but I love potatoes.
Oops.
I ran over.
I think it's only...
I think it's only the...
I think it's the one at the...
At the...
Fishing area.
In fact...
Wait, hold on.
on.
What if we get a job?
I don't know if I need more money, but what if we get a job
that is like too fishing town, you know?
Oh, not enough energy.
Okay, hold on.
I think my chat froze.
Wait, one second.
My chat froze.
I see you guys.
It's cold in here.
I'll freeze.
you i'll free you i think youtube is like me bowling's it
hurts one second one second oh guys can i be a little
vulnerable can i be a little vulnerable i'm a little sad i
thought i was i'm a little sad i did not reach my My goal of
444K subscribers this year.
I feel...
Oh, wait.
I was going to get that job.
I was like, dang.
Dang it.
Not that I really care.
But, you know, it's like...
When you have a goal and you're like, Oh, yeah.
I want to complete the goal.
Oh, wait.
This is good.
This is perfect.
It's a pickup right where I need it.
Yes.
Be a triumph for next year.
I guess it gives me more time to plan something really much
better, though.
For it.
You got really close relatively.
That's true.
I was thinking that also.
Like, I feel like I'm so close.
But, you know, well, the number is close.
Obviously, thousands is not very close, but, you know.
Say no more.
I'm getting 20k bots to sub to your channel.
Those twins are always talking about each other, but have
you ever seen them together?
I haven't.
I think there's three of them.
Ooh, heavy.
Heavy.
All right.
To fishing town!
Uh, I'm struck.
Okay.
Mom, that was so fun.
The makeup was awesome.
I hope the fact that all your stuff...
stuff was so in demand and how all big your lines are.
Did you realize how much we all love you?
Thank you.
I I don't know why.
So you think how close you got considering everything that
happened this year?
Also, you did so many other things on your cool list.
That's true too.
Also, you know, there was a lot of times when I just
couldn't stream because I was out doing other things or
working on other stuff, so you know, ultimately, maybe if I
was able to stream some more, I could have gotten closer,
but yeah.
Oh, it's like I just, you know, I think, I have a lot of, I
have a lot of things I want to not change, but like more
stuff I want to do in 2026 so Pyrobug thank you so much for
the Tony get that thank you uh there's a lot more um things
that I especially just in general want to give back to you
guys so um
not that I'm wishing for it to take this long it'd be crazy
if it hit it right before Halloween no yeah I could what you
mean though gotta break for your health yeah yeah I guess,
you know, it's less of like a...
Oh, I'm sad, that number not big.
And more of just like, you know, when you set a goal for
yourself, you want to reach it.
And when you don't, you feel a little like, ah, is it...
What could I have done better?
Is it me?
Am I, you know...
Am I not likable enough or such?
I don't know, but...
Goals are still goals.
They change and you improve.
Yeah.
Oh, I thought I missed a road.
I think I'm good.
The brainworms.
Proud of you, Minto.
Oh, are you?
Why?
What did I do?
I've had many a brainworm.
I think they, for...
I think Holiday Matsuri will probably be like one of my last
events that I go to.
I don't know what it is, but going to events really makes my
brains, my brain, my brain so sad.
I don't know what it is.
And there might be a few other things that I go to.
planned but
I don't think it's a post con depression thing.
It's while I'm at the con that I'm like feeling it.
I don't know.
It was so weird.
It did so well.
We love you.
Thank you.
Oh boy.
Yeah.
I have a lot of stuff planned for a 2026 thought I'm excited
for.
Things I want to try and patting brainworms away.
Nothing, nothing, nothing.
Thank you.
I set impossible goals for myself at the beginning of every
year so at the end of the year I could use the rage and
anger of myself to feel next year.
That's crazy work.
That's kind of crazy.
Boids.
Boid.
Sometimes I feel more lonely in a crowd.
Oh my gosh though.
What's really, what's really painful is if I'm at an event,
and a lot of my friends are there and they're all hanging
out and I am obviously at the event for you know for for
work so I don't get to hang out with everybody I typically
have FOMO even if I'm at an event because like I don't get
to hang out with anybody and everybody's out having fun and
I'm like oh that looks so fun
so I was like why am I even why do I even bother going
oh wait where am i going where am i going with this package
hello i'm going to dampton and then we gotta go get the ice
chains at clifton dampton first everybody mint con all right
five people show up
smolton dampton
ibu con they'd be so cute that uh before i Before I went
to...
Heaven.
Vicky, no!
Why did you end?
I was gonna raid into you!
No!
That's why we love you.
My best kamiyoshi for being sick.
Thank you so much.
Thank you for the gift!
Get counter-rated.
Dang it.
When I was refreshing the chat, I saw that she was
streaming.
Dang it.
Hello, Buckeyes.
I don't even need to ask how amazing Vicky's singing was.
I already know.
Hello, you!
Is it TOS?
Thank you so much for the 20!
Only five people would show up for Mintcon.
but um before i went to heaven there was a place on like uh
akibator when i was gave one called it was called akiba cia
and uh there always used to be a joke like we're gonna have
we're gonna have a meetup at akiba cia and unfortunately
it's now gone it's now a place like that last year i can't
control thank you so much for the tiny gift thank you it was
like a themed cafe but like cia themed i never even got to
go myself unfortunately shut down where am i oh that's
awesome we should we should come up with another ibu
location drop where all the ibu can meet up wait Weep.
Weep.
It was really CIA-themed.
Yeah!
You've rapidly taken over my Vito-beloving heart.
Wait, where is this place?
Over here?
Nope, just kidding.
The cafe where I am in collab took place.
Oh.
Cafe asan.
Oh, here we go.
Yep.
Wee!
Okay, big money.
Big extra money.
Alright, let's go get our ice chains now.
I don't even know how a cafe can be Cia-A-B's.
What is the menu?
Like, you get...
You get the...
The Wanted List Pasta or something.
I don't know.
You get the...
Is it Burger Mysteries?
I don't know.
Guns.
Just guns.
I'm also going to get some more gas.
Menu is classified.
Oh, that's good.
Yeah, unfortunately we lost so many fun themed cafes.
Especially in like COVID.
Cat.
Wait.
Look at the name of the song.
Sorry, every time I click out of the game, it stops the
audio.
Usually lurk, but you cheered up two of my next misses.
Thank you.
I think I think I will go get some water.
Menu is almost entirely redacted, so it's basically gotcha.
When people are at Godless view, it is for you, not because
you happen to be there as part of a corporal group, but as
an independent of your true copy, you see this.
Thank you.
Thank you, guys.
I'm glad I go get drink real quick I'll be right back wait
let me put on better music
hold on let's go back to the radio
okay this should be better yeah it's better okay I'll be
right back
Thank you for all the little ghosts in the room.
George Costanza with Minto is killing me.
It's iconic.
Where's the gas?
Oh, we're at pizza.
I keep forgetting.
Oh my gosh, is your profile picture?
Is your profile picture?
Hattori Heiji.
Happy birthday!
I hope you had a wonderful, wonderful, wonderful, amazing,
amazing, amazing.
Super fun, super fun, super fun.
Birthday!
I feel bad for anybody whose birthday is around this time.
Your birthday, if your birthday is, like, close to
Christmas, you have the whole, like...
Oh, my presents are doubled up.
Oh, my birthday is turned into a Christmas celebration
instead.
Hmm.
I wish there was a way we could make you feel more included
in your own stuff and meetups.
You deserve it, but it's a tough spot to be in.
Yeah.
Oh, sorry.
I didn't mean to have my tongue come out.
I'm eating raspberries.
Hope you had a nice Crimbo Christmas.
Serpent Eater was PM.
Thank you.
Looking forward to the Jazz Night.
You have more big funds in 2026.
PS, did you see Big Zadu posted his annual holiday event?
No, I didn't.
I'll have to go watch it.
Grimbo.
You again, eh?
I hate to say it, but you're a real hard worker.
It gets real lonely out here, and I don't hate your visits.
But I've got to charge you 3450.
Now go away.
Thank you.
My birthday is Gen 6.
It was not close to Christmas growing up, but in recent
years is also associated.
Ah.
Oh, no.
It always is bad to have like a birthday, you know, around a
strange time or like, you know, yeah.
Oh no!
Oh, whoop, whoop, whoop, there we go.
I guess I feel like the whole Christmas is like, yeah, it's
pretty rough.
also you can't really have like a birthday party on your
like as a kid you can't have a birthday party on your
birthday because your friends will be spending time with
their family and all so
drift drift drift all right let's go get these chains on us
and then we'll head over to
head to wait i went the wrong way
January January I think so do ghosts even celebrate
birthdays well like okay my birthday is like the day I was I
became a ghost so it's like it's like the birth of it's my
death day but I was born into a ghost so I don't know it
depends on how you you know I just call it birthday
otherwise You know, I don't want you guys to get all
confused and all.
I'm always thinking to you guys.
Ice chains.
Oh?
It's been so nice to play with all our friends the last few
days.
MK must miss Seb so much.
I can't imagine not having my closest friend while everyone
else has found each other.
Ice chains.
You should help you keep your speed on the ice.
That will cost $2.99.
Thank you very much.
All set.
Head to the factory just west of Mountain Town.
Let's go, baby.
All right.
Turn around.
And we're good to go.
Mountain Town delivery, too.
I don't think we need to.
I need more money, do we?
Oops.
My car is so sensitive.
Wonder if we can drive across the lake.
I think so.
But the factory is over this way, so we gotta go back.
$500.
Oh, don't say that.
If it's real, I'll cry.
I'll get the... I'll get the...
The fishing rod or something.
Oh.
I love raspberry.
Okay, we are at...
Eastern.
We need to go to West.
It is over there, right?
Pretty sure that's it right there.
Yumbo.
When is raspberry season?
Is it now?
Summer.
But it's not now.
Oops.
They're still delicious, don't get me wrong.
I think it's August, I see.
Oh!
Mid-Summer Wars.
Well, they're still yummy.
It ain't Rashpin Time.
Factory.
Here we go!
This place is new.
Exciting.
I was just gonna ignore him.
Hello.
You've got the ice chains?
Good.
It's a straight shot to the factory.
You'll need some speed.
I'll radio you once you're inside.
I would go with you, but my programming doesn't seem to
allow it.
months to get in.
Ever since...
Anyway.
Ever since SEB!
Yeah, it's orange season.
It's awesome.
Make sure to top up on energy before heading in.
Good luck in there.
I have one cup of coffee.
We'll go get some more.
Oops.
Excuse me.
buy some coffee and make it wait speculation are you a reset
seb i think so wait but i'd have to make the coffee oh my
gosh i want to see what's going on with what's what's your
name elsie you know i always find myself in need of some
dirt and i can never find any then one day it just started
showing up.
Like, dirt from heaven.
Yeah, okay, great, good.
Scenarius, gray.
Welcome to membership.
Thank you.
Rain and dirt.
Okay, sorry.
I think we need to go a little bit out of the way.
Uh.
I have to find a store, and I have to find some coffee.
Okay.
I'm gonna go...
I should have never got this dang coffee pot.
I don't want to spend my money on the firewood because it's
so expensive but I think I will can you buy coffee at the
bakery I think you buy tea there which is a little different
the tea prevents you from over from freezing but it does not
replenish your energy
you could use on his cat oh I could okay thank you that's so
true you're right you're right you're right But I need to
get a store- wait, um...
Is there a store up here?
Am I crazy?
Wait, let's go down.
Nice.
Okay.
Oh,
sorry, I was scratching my head.
Like a monkey.
Wrong way.
Wrong way, Gim.
Oh!
Good thing we have no deliveries, huh?
Minky!
We just gotta go find a grocery store.
Oh, come on!
Game didn't put me backwards.
I'd be fine.
Okay, there we go.
There she goes.
There she blows.
Where's the dang grocery store?
I'm starving here.
What is this food desert?
Uh-oh.
Alright, let's find a place.
Hmm.
Looking for a grocery store.
That's the bakery.
Insurance premiums just...
No, no, no, no.
Just don't report it.
Here we go!
Uh-oh, my energy is so low.
Coffee powder.
ST-49 terminated.
Offline!
Have an easy day.
That will cost you...
I'll just be here.
That should be enough, right?
Actually, I'll buy one more.
He's been terminated!
He's offline!
Okay.
Let's...
Let's get to...
Our friend!
Okay, perfect.
Numbers, what do they mean?
Oh wait, I think I need my pot first.
No.
Please.
Why can't I use it?
Oh my god.
We got scammed.
We got scammed for real.
Oh man.
Okay, I'll go buy one.
He literally said it can be used on...
I'm not blaming you.
I'm not blaming whoever suggested it in the chat.
You were so smart for thinking that.
The game lied to us.
Luckily, the store is just a short ways away.
It's just that the firewood is sold.
Darn, expansive.
I really don't think we need any more.
I don't think we need any more money, though.
I think we're about at endgame.
I blame you, chat.
I could never, I could never.
I'm scared of, like, using this wrong.
You know?
Leave.
There we go.
My dog!
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god.
You're really talented and creative person.
We throw the Jurassic Park Arcade stream.
It is an August heavy rolling.
My world is brighter with...
Ah, stop!
Thank you, Dan.
Thank you so much!
Thank you!
Okay, we're heating up.
We're heating up.
Run, run, run.
Okay.
Place pot.
Perfect.
Oh my god, we're doing it!
We're doing it!
Okay, so you only need two for a thing.
Perfect.
Are you guys fighting?
Cook.
My homemade coffee.
Yeah, would you drink it?
I think this is actually dirt.
This is the dirt that the bakery person was talking about.
Alright, let's drink a cup.
Actually, I'm gonna have one later when we get there.
We'll top off there so I don't waste any.
I don't even know if, like, I need this much, but better to
be safe than sorry.
He said we need speed, huh?
into Minto, huh?
Oh, the coffee?
Oh my god.
That guy was just like...
Oh yeah.
I don't know if he should be drinking that anymore.
Oh my god.
Go, go, go, go, go.
I think it's coming after us.
Woo!
We made it!
Apparently, there was like some people that he gave expired
to.
or something.
And he was like, no, no, for me, it was fine.
But he was like, it's been so long now, I wouldn't.
I probably wouldn't anymore.
Okay, let's drink that coffee.
Does coffee really expire, though?
Real minto hours.
Yeah!
Yes, really fast.
It can mold.
No way.
Seriously?
Seriously!
Head to the factory just west of Mountain Town.
Our goal is to buy the fishing rod.
It goes stale at least.
Even bottled water expire.
I guess that's true.
Wait, what's happening?
Leave?
Oh.
Yeah.
Let's get my lighter out.
Ground copy stales faster than whole beans, though.
Let's see it.
Maybe I'm safe, I don't know.
What is this factory for?
We're in here, but...
Do you copy?
Great.
Try to find a control center.
Hey.
I never got your name.
I'm sorry for all this.
When he started up, I really thought Seb had come back.
Seems like Iziko really is shut down cloud-computed agents
for good.
So, I guess we are like, we are Seb, but not really.
Maybe Seb without the memories or something.
friend back.
So sad.
Same character, but different player.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Seb and I were friends.
Good friends.
They were a little rigid around the edges.
But we became as close of friends as two ML agents could be.
ML?
Seb supported my dream of one day leaving this place i
thought was terrible but i think their heart was here with
the shop keepers imagine living life as someone who is
already existing person just having to talk to their friend
without knowing oh i know mario luigi oh they saw each other
a lot more through the deliveries i was just fixing things
in the background sep ultimately gave up their job to be
with me what is over here anyway i'm just running into walls
i love the way they hop around when they walk i wish i could
walk more in the game because it's so cute
after seb shut down all i wanted was to join them that's why
i was trying so hard to get into the factory But it's been
really nice seeing the shopkeepers blossom into their own
selves.
Have they?
They're kind of freaky.
All I want now is to keep them safe.
For Seb.
Even if it means rebooting them.
We must reboot them.
Oh, is this the control?
Ooh.
Choose.
this this when i first started up the game it actually had
like this this started up like this easy call recovery disk
unavailable st units hydropower
oh wait what
sometimes being your own self is being freaky miss freak
phantom spread his code where the endings are yeah what does
it mean though sd units or hydropower
i'm guessing sd units means the shopkeepers and hydropower
means sub or something
SD unit sounds like you'd be spread in the code.
That's so true.
Let's try SD units.
False present.
Oh yeah, here we go.
Reboot, wait.
Reboot SD units.
Reboot some personality may be lost.
No.
Hydro power shuts everyone down while SD unit just resets
every way's personality.
will they even be themselves then some of them were kind of
jerks anyway no the gas they were just sundere the gas the
gas store they were fine you need the recovery disc to save
the personalities ah which i didn't get dang that's okay
reboot have an easy day reboot is what i got achievement do
you copy it looks like you didn't need my help after all
you've brought our friends peace for now I'm the only one
who will ever know I'll look after them with great care it
just doesn't feel right keeping them in this cycle amelia
thank you so much for the redirect hello hello all my
friends are redirecting into me today thank you we're at the
end of the game though so spoiler spoiler warning there has
to be another way i guess you have to thank you so much for
the gift
Spreading the code?
I'm spreading my code?
I'm spreading the code?
What?
Oh my gosh, wait, that's the ending?
No way, that's it!
Oh, that's it!
Faith Valray, thank you!
Thank you, thank you!
That's it, I was so sad!
I just rebooted them and that was it.
Oh.
That's so sad.
I mean, I guess they're fine.
Maybe?
I wish I didn't have... Let's see.
Hold on.
If I play a new game...
Oh my gosh, I just realized I never, like, saved or
anything.
Oh, wait, here we go.
If I resume...
Wait, hold on.
Let's see if I can do the other ending.
A.D.K.
who gifted me, but thank you.
Thank you!
Wait, where are we?
Oh, I'm here!
Let's try... Let's get the ending.
other ending.
I need more speed.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Let's get the other ending, and then I know that there's
probably the third one with the disc I won't be able to get,
but that's okay.
Oh my god.
Let's go.
I really, I just realized I got all that coffee.
I really didn't need it at all.
I was like, imagine if I don't eat all this coffee, and I
was...
Right?
You can get the third one right after this.
No way, really?
Ice cracking is uncomfy sounding.
It is!
I don't like it either.
Thank you for playing.
Grab this to play over the weekend.
Yeah!
Oh my gosh, if you just want to, like, a vibe...
vibe and going around game, this is, like, one of those
types of games for real.
Sorry to stick around to the end, but good night, me though.
Things are trying to stick around for so long!
Well, I'm almost done.
No worries, no worries.
Strand game.
It's actual Strand game.
Okay, let's see.
Okay, dokey.
I'll just skip through the dialogue if that's okay,
everybody.
earlier like dredge yeah oh i missed dredge that was i don't
know the last time i got like so hooked on a game you know
it's such a good feeling to get like so into a game that
you're like oh my gosh i can't i can't put it down oh i love
dredge ironically for me at least this game was bundled with
dredge oh really like a like a or something.
It was like just the right fishing game that I wanted.
Wait, when did he start contacting me?
The music in this game is so good.
I'm gonna get the soundtrack.
Wait, isn't he supposed to contact me on the walkie?
Did I watch Akiba Mid Wars?
I did!
Wait, why isn't he talking?
Do we spread in code again?
You know, every time I see you, I automatically go to line
10 because that's what you are.
A perfect...
Stab it.
Oh, he's dead.
Because I rebooted?
Wait, I wonder what the other guys are like then.
Wait, the shopkeepers.
Wait.
Wait!
The save wasn't before the ending, but it was after!
Oh my gosh, the silence is deafening.
Julie!
Welcome to membership!
Thank you!
What the heck!
The music's stopping, so scary.
I see, like, shut down in there, you know?
Wait, so if I hydropower?
Well, I feel like I have to try, you know?
Let's see.
Turbine.
1, 2, 3, 4 status.
Shut down, hydrodam.
All shopkeepers will shut down.
Shut down ending.
I need to frame step the vine to see that code.
Is that it?
We'll go look at the shopkeepers now.
I just noticed like how crazy looking this factor is.
I have no radio!
Oh, just kidding, I do.
Is that the campfire?
Wait!
No.
They don't talk.
They're just blank now.
I can't wait if I like try to buy it it won't let me oh my
gosh can I steal it I stole
and I was even getting cold in there there's like no
anything I stole um
Is it easy to get the third end?
Just keep scanning.
There's no radio.
You can just take the recovery disc.
You have to get a disc, yeah, but where are you at?
I can tell you where it is.
Grab the recovery disc now that the shopkeeper...
Where?
I don't remember seeing one though.
Is it in here?
Oh, the pawn shop.
It's Easton pawn shop.
Thank you.
I think we're in Weston right now.
Shortcut.
Alright, we'll do it real fast.
I don't want to end it like this.
It would be too depressing, no?
I feel like I have to complete it.
I feel like I must do it.
For Easton.
But it makes sense that you can just...
Oh, I'm getting a signal, though.
I heard some noise.
Wait, I think I need to go up there.
Oh, it's fine.
I'll just do a loop.
It would be pretty sad.
Yeah, it's so quiet and everything.
I don't like it.
It's scanning.
I'm getting, like, sometimes something, but...
develop a funny guy's normal IT conversation
are there still trains?
Is that what I just heard?
Hmm,
we dubbed the logs doggo.
Alright, enter.
Oh, it's $300 usually.
Oh my gosh!
Oh, thank goodness I didn't think I had to buy it.
Yoink.
Mine now, baby.
It's for the sake of them.
Did I?
I don't know if I mentioned that because I got Netflix for
Breaking Bad.
I watched K-Pop Demon Hunters today because I was like, I
want to know what the hype is like and everything.
I thought it was cute.
I thought they're so cute when they're just like, we do this
for you.
for the fans.
That's me right now.
I'm like, I'm doing this for the villagers.
I did at the beginning.
Okay.
Thanks for sticking around for the whole stream.
I thought it was pretty cute.
I mean, there were some parts that I was like, ah, you know,
it was a little cringy, but it's not cringy in like a It was
your favorite Saja boy.
I don't I think they all, I don't know, they, I wish they
were like animated different.
Maybe baby.
Because it's funny.
I almost wish they didn't only sing golden because I like
the other song really a lot.
The little part of me.
This is what it sounds like.
I really like that song.
But I feel like the Huntrix...
Oh, whoops.
I thought...
I was like, what is that?
Something's in my way.
I don't need sleep.
I need a happy Minky.
No, sleep!
I'll be happy if you sleep.
My offensive take is K-pop Demon Hunters is simple here for
normies.
Oh.
Oh, oh, oh, no, that's powder!
That's the powder I stole.
I like that one better than Golden.
Yeah!
I really like it.
Seek shelter.
Oh, shoot.
Uh-oh.
This is not good.
Everything is cold.
Uh-oh.
Shoot.
Wait, is this gonna be possible?
I do have two logs.
But it seems I'm okay.
in here?
If it gets bad, then obviously I'll put them down and...
Seems like I'm okay in here, though.
That was a bug, apparently.
What?
Okay.
Alright, now we go do the disc.
Which I have.
This.
Oh, this also was light, but I'm trying to...
One cold elevator.
Alright.
Complete the ritual.
Do you think I'll bring him back, though?
Mk?
Will he be okay?
He's Mk?
Just check the world record for this game.
They're not expected to be sub-10 minutes.
for for for this ending maybe with the disc you just do a
bunch of jobs and you get the $300 and then you do it wait
no how do you get across the ice is it glitchless?
it can't be unless they don't like the true strats of
getting down the mountains
it's never glitchless I'm not like It's not that I prefer
Glitchless, but you know I think it's always more impressive
When it's glitchless, obviously Like something about task
runs just don't Interest me I like seeing I don't want to
see a AI take a person's job Like I just really like
Watching a person do themselves Do it, it's so much, it's so
interesting some glitches are harder than normal gameplay
that's true i'm that's very true and some things yeah like
you have to like be pixel perfect in terms of like wall
clipping or something i get that i get that tasas is like
proof of concept theoretical demista yeah yeah yeah but i
know i know some people that'll like kind of be like oh my
gosh this we've discovered an even faster bastard run or
something.
I'm just kind of like, oh, well, you know.
That's just my personal opinion.
Choose.
Howdy, simply wanted to say have a good day.
You too, Mario.
Luigi.
Recovery disk detected.
SD unit recovery.
Data okay.
Repair and restore.
Restore SD units.
Restore ending!
We
get credits this time.
Sam, see?
Is that it?
So yeah, I just turned everything back to normal?
Glitched and glitchless are both really impressive in
totally different ways.
No, they'll get me wrong, I agree.
I just prefer watching glitchless runs than glitched ones.
My opinion.
There's a smidge more after the credits.
Okay, cool.
Oh my gosh, the slim, slim team of people.
Holy cow.
Cat friends.
There's more people for localization than anything else.
Yeah, there's an outline by the truck of like a cat.
Okay.
Turn up the music.
Same amount of people you'd see on a AAA type of game in the
90s.
Is it Seb?
Thank you for playing.
Let's see what happens after credits.
Nothing happened!
Did I get one guide?
Wait, the sun is down though.
That's kind of funny.
like it really does save before the factory or after the
factory
there's nothing here anymore MK is not even here would he be
at his house you think?
yo here's a million dollar idea individually wrapped cookies
that have ambiguous notes inside I'll call them fate cookies
sounds similar to something that already exists?
I don't think so.
Oh, he's back to normal.
Are these the...
These are the guys, the town's folk we wanted to save.
I see.
Oops.
No, no, he has a point.
Fate cookies.
Honestly, though, sometimes they should just be called like
mild advice cookies they're not quite fortune they are
they're very like you should
you should um
promise mascot agency oh wait i've heard of that one i think
if you like this one thank you so much for the super chat
thank you um i've seen ads yeah there's sometimes ads on
them it's so i i don't use this word very lightly it's so
cringe like it's so oh it's like oh my gosh you can't even i
can't even open a dang cookie without seeing an ad for
something it's so bad this is like actually just cringe
It's like, yeah, like, it's actually an ick.
It'll be forever, remember, once a liar, always a liar, in a
cookie.
Who was I being warned about?
Oh my gosh.
That's like saying once a cheater, always a cheater.
Hold on, sorry, I gotta fix my contact.
Oh, we made a little bit of, we caused a little bit of
chaos, but it's okay.
My contact has been fixed.
Add block on the cookie.
Wait, so original spot was like up here.
Let's see if he's here or if...
Oh!
Nailed it.
Okay.
Made Mintour's contacts?
Yes, I do!
Okay.
We go to house.
We go to MK Cabin.
Wait, oh, here.
In real life, cookies give you ads, but on the internet, ads
give you cookies.
Makes you think.
Why in, out the oven, if, of the oven in?
Okay.
You, you restored the shopkeepers.
I didn't know it was even possible.
If I'd known I...
how much this means to me, my wonderful friend.
Thank you.
A thousand times.
I think...
I think this means there's a chance I can find Seb again.
I'm leaving right now.
Even if it's just a small chance, I have to see if EasyCoal
made a backup.
I'm going to
confident, I'm leaving our friends in great hands with you
around.
You've done a beautiful thing.
Repair the ST units and tell him, okay.
Oh, I didn't do that.
I didn't do a fresh moron.
Oh!
He's gonna go find Seb!
Yippee!
Yay!
Now you don't Look at the fishing ending.
It's okay.
Yay.
I was the one in the May Cafe with my buddy on FaceTime.
Yeah!
Thanks for being his first meet and greet.
Thank you!
Thank you for being such an awesome friend.
I had so much fun with this game.
Thank you guys for joining me for easy delivery code.
Another one for the list?
Damn.
There we go!
You know that to you, you're just you, but to us, you're
beautiful, amazing, and irreplaceable.
You always make our lives brighter and more fun.
And we love you!
We're always here to burn those brainworms as much as you
need.
Thank you for the stream.
Oh, I'm sorry, I actually clicked out.
Oh.
Thank you!
Thank you.
Tri-Princess, thank you so much.
Thank you, guys.
I really, really appreciate it.
Yeah, I had a lot of fun with this game, so I'm going to go
get some breasts, and I suggest you do as well.
How long?
It's been seven hours.
So, it's been a while, though, since I've done a longer
stream like this.
It didn't even feel like it, I feel...
There was a bit of a slog in the middle, I would admit, but
yeah.
And I recommend an anime that's going to come out next year.
It's called Kaiju Girl.
Kaiju Girl caramelized.
It's really cute and wholesome.
Original Shoujo manga.
Kaiju Girl.
Are you going to hit 15 in 2025?
I will.
I'm on track for it, baby.
Yeah.
But yeah, thank you, guys.
Nice!
Thank you, thank you!
And I hope you had fun too, I hope you...
I hope it was at least a...
Wait, where's the music at?
Come on.
There we go.
I hope it was chill, if anything, so...
Um, but yeah, I had a lot of fun, so...
Thank you, everybody!
Osaparo, thank you!
Thank you!
Have you heard of the anime Zombie Land Song?
Yeah, I love Zombie Land Song, though.
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
What's up it, what's up it, what's up it, what's up it,
you'll get some rest!
Bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye
bye bye bye bye bye